for online content creators the
unavoidable subject of 2021 has been
nfts from incredibly cringe-worthy ape
profile picks to incomprehensibly
tasteless tributes to deceased
celebrities to six-figure sales of the
original copy of a meme it is the thing
that is currently dominating the
collective brain space of digital
artists and sucking up all the oxygen in
the room and i do want to talk about
that i want to talk about my opinions on
nfts and digital ownership and scarcity
and all the myriad dimensions of the
issue but i don't
just want to talk about nfts i can't
just talk about nfts because ultimately
they are just a symbol of so much more
and it is that more that is ultimately
important so let me tell you a story
in 2008 the economy functionally
collapsed the basic chain reaction was
this banks came up with a thing called a
mortgage-backed security a financial
instrument that could be traded or
collected that was based on a bundle of
thousands of individual mortgages based
on the general reluctance of banks to
issue mortgages the risk aversion in
lending someone hundreds of thousands of
dollars that they'll pay off over the
course of potentially decades these
bonds were seen as especially stable
however they were also immensely
profitable for the banks who both issue
the mortgages and the bonds because of
that perceived stability a lot of other
financial organizations like pension
funds and hedge funds use them as the
backbone of their investment portfolio
in this arrangement a mortgage becomes
more profitable to the bank issuing the
mortgage as a component of a bond than
it is as a mortgage proportionally the
returns per mortgage from the bond are
just that much better than the returns
from the isolated mortgage there are
some problems though problem one is that
the biggest returns on a bond come from
when it first hits the market a new bond
that creates new security sales is worth
more than an old bond that is slowly
appreciating but not seeing much trade
problem two is that there are a finite
number of people and houses in america
the market has to level out at a natural
ceiling as eventually all or nearly all
mortgages are packaged into bonds thus
very few new bonds can be generated and
sold so here's the incentives that are
created one it's good for banks if there
are more houses that they can issue
mortgages for
two the more mortgages issued the better
because a bad mortgage is worth more as
a component of a bond than a good
mortgage that's not part of a bond so
real estate developers find that they
have a really easy time getting funding
from banks for creating vast new suburbs
full of houses that can be sold to
generate mortgages but rather than
building the kind of housing that most
people actually need and want they focus
specifically on the kinds of upper
middle class houses that fit into the
sweet spot from the perspective of the
banks packaging the bonds buyers in turn
find that they have a suspiciously easy
time getting a mortgage despite the fact
that for most people the economy wasn't
doing so great wages were stagnant and
yet even though developers were going
absolutely haywire building new housing
the houses being built were all out of
their price range to begin with and
counter-intuitively this massive
increase in supply wasn't driving down
the price this is because the houses
were being bought just mostly not by
people intending to live in them they
were being bought by speculators who
would then maybe rent them out or often
just leave them vacant with the intent
to sell a couple years later because
speculators were buying up the supply it
created synthetic demand the price keeps
going up because speculators keep buying
which creates the illusion that the
value is going up which attracts more
speculators who buy up more supply and
further inflate the price these
speculators are enabled by a system that
is prioritizing generating new mortgages
purely for the sake of having more
mortgages to package into bonds the down
payments are low and the mortgages all
have a really attractive teaser rate
meaning that for the first three to
seven years of the mortgage the monthly
payments are rock bottom as low as a few
hundred dollars per month against a
mortgage that would normally charge
thousands caught up in all this are
legitimate buyers who have been lured
into signing for a mortgage that they
can't afford by aggressive salespeople
who have an incentive to generate
mortgages that they can then sell to a
bank who can put it into a bond to sell
to pension funds to make a line go up
because it's good when the line goes up
it's a bubble the bubble burst as the
teaser rates on the mortgages started to
expire the monthly cost jumped up and
since the demand was synthetic there
were no actual buyers for the
speculators to sell the houses to so the
speculators start dumping stock which
finally drives prices down but because
the original price was so inflated the
new price is still out of reach of most
actual buyers legitimate buyers caught
in the middle find their rates jumping
too but because the price of the house
is going down as speculators try and
dump their stock the price of the house
goes down relative to the mortgage
issued and thus they can't refinance and
are locked into paying the original
terms unable to sell the house and
unable to afford the monthly payments
the owners legitimate and speculators
default on their mortgages they stop
paying eventually the default rate
reaches criticality and the bonds fail
as the bonds fail this impacts all the
first order buyers of the bonds hedge
funds pension funds retirement savings
funds and the like it also cascades
through all derivatives which are
financial products that take their value
directly from the value of the bond this
creates a knock-on effect huge segments
of the economy turn out to be dead trees
rotten to the core but as a rotten tree
falls it still shreds its neighbors and
crushes anything below it it was a
failure precipitated by a combination of
greed active fraud and willful blindness
at all levels of power the banks issuing
the bad mortgages were the same banks
selling the bonds and providing the
capital to build the houses to generate
the mortgages the ratings agencies
checking the bonds were themselves
publicly traded and dependent on being
in good relations with the banks
incentivized to rubber stamp whatever
rating would make their client happy the
regulatory agencies that should have
seen the problem coming were gutted by
budget cuts and mired in conflicts of
interest as employees use their
positions in regulation to secure higher
paying jobs in industry and the cherry
on top the people largely responsible
for it all knew that because they and
their toxic products were so interwoven
into the foundations of the economy they
could count on a bailout from the
government because no matter how rotten
they were
they were very large trees
this naked display of greed and fraud
created what would be fertile soil for
both anti-capitalist movements and hyper
capitalist movements both groups of
people who saw themselves as being
screwed over by the system with one
group diagnosing the problem as the
system's inherently corrupt and
corrupting incentives and the other
seeing the crisis as a consequence of
too much regulation too much exclusion
the hyper-capitalist or
anarcho-capitalist argument is that in a
less constrained market there would be
more incentive to call foul that
regulation had only succeeded in
creating an in-group that was
effectively able to conspire without
competition of course this argument
fails to consider that a substantial
number of people within the system did
in fact get fabulously wealthy
specifically by betting against the
synthetic cess of the market but
regardless
into this environment in 2009 arrived
bitcoin an all-electronic peer-to-peer
currency philosophically bitcoin and
cryptocurrency in general was paraded as
an end to banks and centralized currency
this is what will form the bedrock both
philosophical and technological that
nfts will be built on top of it's a bit
of a hike from here to the board api
club so i guess get ready for that
strap in as we get into this we're going
to have to deal with a lot of vocabulary
need to deal with a lot of complexity
some of this is the result of systems
that are very technically intricate and
some of this is from systems that are
poorly designed or deliberately obtuse
in order to make them difficult to
understand and thus appear more
legitimate the entire subject sits at
the intersection of two fields that are
notoriously prone to hyped-based
obfuscation computer tech and finance
and inherence a lot of bad habits from
both with a reputation for making things
deliberately more difficult to
understand specifically to create the
illusion that only they are smart enough
to understand it mining and minting are
both methods of making tokens which are
the base thing that blockchains deal
with but the two are colloquially
different processes where mining is a
coin token created as a result of the
consensus protocol and minting is
user-initiated addition of a token to a
blockchain all blockchains are made of
nodes and these nodes can be watcher
nodes minor nodes or validator nodes
though most minor nodes are also
validator nodes fractionalization is the
process of taking one asset and creating
a new asset that represents portions of
the original so you get dog a memecoin
crypto d5 venture capital fund backed by
the fractionalization of the original
doge meme sold as an nft to pleaser dow
on the ethereum network i'm sorry
some of this is just gonna be like that
the idea behind cryptocurrency is that
your digital wallet functions the same
as a bank account there's no need for a
bank to hold and process your
transactions because rather than holding
a sum that conceptually represents
physical currency the crypto coins in
your crypto wallet are the actual money
and because this money isn't issued by a
government it is resistant to historical
cash crises like hyperinflation caused
by governments devaluing their currency
on purpose or by accident it brings the
flexibility and anonymity of cash and
barter to the digital realm allowing
individuals to transact without
oversight or intermediaries and in a one
paragraph pitch you can see the appeal
there's a compelling narrative there but
of course in the 12 years since then
none of that played out as designed
bitcoin was structurally too slow and
expensive to handle regular commerce the
whole thing basically came out the gate
as a speculative financial vehicle and
so the only consumer market that proved
to be a viable use was buying and
selling prohibited drugs where the high
fees rapid price fluctuations and
multi-hour transaction times were
mitigated by
receiving lsd in the mail a week later
and as far as banking is concerned
bitcoin was never designed to solve the
actual problems created by the banking
industry only to be the new medium by
which they operated the principal
offering wasn't revolution but at best a
changing of the guard the gripe is not
with the outcomes of 2008 but the fact
that you had to be well connected in
order to get in on the grift in 2006 and
even the change of the guard is an
illusion old money finance [ __ ] like
the winklevoss twins were some of the
first big names to jump onto crypto
where they remain to this day financial
criminal jordan belfort convicted of
fraud for running pump and dump schemes
and barred for life from trading
regulated securities or acting as a
broker loves crypto venture capitalist
chris dixon who has made huge bank off
the old web in his role as a general
partner at vc firm anderson horowitz is
super popular in the nft space he likes
to paint himself as an outsider underdog
fighting the gatekeepers but he also
sits on the boards of coinbase a large
cryptocurrency exchange that makes money
by being the gatekeeper collecting a fee
on all entries and exits to the crypto
economy and oculus vr which is owned by
meta near facebook peter thiel who also
went from wealthy to ultra wealthy off
the web 2 boom via paypal loves crypto
and is friends with a bunch of eugenics
advocates who promote cryptocurrency as
a return to sound money for a whole
bunch of extremely racist reasons
because when they start talking about
banks and bankers they mean jews some of
the largest institutional holders of
cryptocurrency are the exact same
investment banks that created the
subprime loan crash
rather than being a reprieve to the
people harmed by the housing bubble the
people whose savings and retirements
were unknown to them being gambled on
smoke cryptocurrency instantly became
the new playground for smoke vendors
this is a really important point to
stress cryptocurrency does nothing to
address 99 of the problems with the
banking industry because those problems
are patterns of human behavior their
incentives their social structures their
modalities the problem is what people
are doing to others not that the
building they're doing it in has the
word bank on the outside in addition to
not fixing problems bitcoin also came
with a pretty substantial drawback the
innovation of bitcoin over previous
attempts at digital currency was to
employ a distributed append only ledger
a kind of database where new entries can
only be added to the end and then to
have several different nodes called
validators compete over who gets to
validate the next update these are
respectively the blockchain and proof of
work verification now proof of work has
an interesting history as a technology
typically being deployed as a deterrent
to misbehavior for example if you
require that every email sent the user's
computer has to compute a small math
program it places a trivial load onto
normal users sending a few dozen or even
a couple hundred emails a day but places
a massive load on the infrastructure of
anyone attempting to spam millions of
emails
how it works in bitcoin simply put is
that when a block of transactions are
ready to be recorded to the ledger all
of the mining nodes in the network
compete with one another to solve a
cryptographic math problem that's based
on the data inside the block
effectively they're competing to figure
out the equation that yields a specific
result when the contents of the block
are fed into it with the complexity of
the desired result getting deliberately
more difficult based on the total
processing power available to the
network
once the math problem has been solved
the rest of the validation network can
easily double check the work since the
contents of the block can be fed into
the proposed solution and it either
spits out the valid answer or fails if
the equation works and the consensus of
validator signs off on it the block is
added to the bottom of the ledger and
the miner who solved the problem first
is rewarded with newly generated bitcoin
the complexity of the answer that the
computers are trying to solve scales up
based on the network's processing power
specifically to incur heavy diminishing
returns as a protection against an
attack on the network where someone just
builds a bigger computer and takes over
critics pointed out that this created
new problems adversarial validation
would deliberately incur escalating
processing costs which would in turn
generate perverse structural incentives
that would quickly reward capital
holders and lock out any individual that
wasn't already obscenely wealthy because
while the escalating proof of work
scheme incurs heavy diminishing returns
diminishing returns are still returns so
more would always go to those with the
resources to build the bigger rig no
matter what bitcoin future was
envisioned in the here and now computer
hardware can be bought with dollars
rather than dismantling corrupt power
structures this would just become a new
tool for existing wealth and that's
exactly what happened thus began an arms
race for bigger and bigger processing
rigs followed by escalating demands for
the support systems hardware engineers
hvac and operating space needed to put
those rigs in and don't worry we're not
forgetting the power requirements these
rigs draw an industrial amount of power
and because of the winner takes all
nature of the competition huge amounts
of redundant work are being done and
discarded estimates for this power
consumption are hard to verify the data
is very complex spread across hundreds
of operators around the globe who move
frequently in search of cheap
electricity and it's all pretty heavily
politicized but even conservative
estimates from within the crypto mining
industry puts the some energy cost of
bitcoin processing on par with the power
consumption of a small industrialized
nation now evangelists will counter that
the global banking industry also uses a
lot of power gesturing at things like
idle atms humming away all night long
which is strictly speaking not untrue on
a factual level the entire global
banking industry does in fact use a lot
of total electricity but for scale it
takes six hours of that sustained power
draw for the bitcoin network to process
as many transactions as visa handles in
one minute and during that time visa is
using fractions of a cent of electricity
per transaction and that's just visa
that's one major institution so like yes
globally the entirety of the banking
industry consumes a lot of power and a
non-trivial portion of that is waste
that could be better allocated but it's
also the global banking industry for
seven billion people and not the hobby
horse of a few hundred thousand gambling
addicts so just to head all this off at
the pass bitcoin and proof-of-work
cryptocurrency aren't incentivizing a
move to green energy sources like solar
and wind they are offsetting it because
electrical consumption electrical waste
is the value that underpins bitcoin
miners spend x dollars in electricity to
mine a bitcoin they expect to be able to
sell that coin for at least x plus
profit when new power sources come
online and the price of electricity goes
down they don't let x go down they build
a bigger machine
2012 vitalik buterin a crypto enthusiast
and butthurt warlock maine set out to
fix what he saw as the failings and
inflexibilities of bitcoin rather than
becoming the new digital currency a
thing that people actually use to buy
stuff bitcoin had become an unwieldy
speculative financial instrument too
slow and expensive to use for anything
other than stunt purchases of expensive
cars it was infested with money
laundering and mired in bad press after
the fbi shut down silk road you couldn't
even buy drugs with it anymore in
practice you couldn't do anything with
your bitcoin but bet on it lock up money
you already have in the hopes that
bitcoin goes up later and pray you don't
lose it all in a scam lose access to
your wallet or have it all stolen by an
exchange the result launched in 2014 was
ethereum a competing cryptocurrency that
boasted lower fees faster transaction
times a reduced electrical footprint and
most notably a sophisticated processing
functionality while the bitcoin
blockchain only tracks the location and
movement of bitcoins ethereum would be
broader in addition to tracking ether
coins the ledger would also be able to
track arbitrary blocks of data as long
as they were compatible with the
structure of the ethereum network these
blocks of data could even be programs
that would utilize the validation
network as a distributed virtual machine
vitalik envisioned this as a vast
infinite machine duplicated and
distributed across thousands or millions
of computers a system onto which the
entire history of a new internet could
be immutably written immune to
censorship and impossible for
governments to take down he saw it
dismantling banks and other intermediary
industries allowing everyone to be their
own bank to be their own stockbroker to
bypass governments regulators and
insurance agencies his peers envisioned
a future where ethereum became not just
a repository of financial transactions
but of identity with deeds driver's
licenses professional credentials
medical records educational achievements
and employment history turned into
tokens and stored immutable and eternal
on the chain through crypto and the
ethereum virtual machine they could
bring all the benefits of wall street
investors and silicon valley venture
capitalists to the poorest people of the
world the unbanked and forgotten this
heady high-minded philosophy is outlined
in great detail in the journalistic
abortion the infinite machine by failed
journalist turned crypto shill camila
russo
the book is actually really interesting
not for the merits of the writing russo
fails to interrogate the validity or
rationality of even the simplest claims
and falls just shy of hagiography by
occasionally noting that something was a
bit tacky or embarrassing but only just
shy
she tells florid stories about the
impoverished people that vitalik and
friends claim to be working to save but
never once considers that the solutions
offered might not actually work or that
the people claiming to want to solve
those problems might not even be working
on them that's actually a big issue
since the entire crypto space during the
entire time that russo's book covers was
absolutely awash with astroturfing
schemes where two guys would go to some
small community in laos or angola take a
bunch of pictures of people at a crypto
investing seminar generate some
headlines for their coin or fund and
then peace out for years dudes were
going around asking vendors if they
could slap a bitcoin sticker onto the
back of the cash register because the
optics of making it look like a place
takes bitcoin was cheaper and easier
than actually using bitcoin as a
currency we have an entire decade of
credulous articles about how venezuela
and chile are on the verge of switching
entirely to crypto based entirely on the
claim of two trust fund dudes from san
bernardino a whole 10 years littered
with discarded press releases about dell
and microsoft and square bringing crypto
to the consumers before just
quietly discontinuing their services
after a year or two when they realized
the demand isn't actually there the fact
the development of ethereum was
extremely dependent on a hundred
thousand dollar fellowship grant from
peter thiel is mentioned but the
ideological implications of that
connection are never explored the entire
subject occupies a single paragraph
sprinkled as flavor into a story about
vitalik and his co-developers airing
their grievances about some petty
infighting the book is mostly useful for
its value as a point of referenced
against reality it's a very thorough if
uncritical document of absolutely insane
claims the idea was that the traits of
blockchain technology such as having no
central point of failure being
uncensorable cutting out intermediaries
and being immutable could also benefit
other applications besides money
financial instruments like stocks and
bonds and commodities like gold were the
obvious targets but people were also
talking about putting other
representations of value like property
deeds and medical records on the
blockchain too those efforts admirable
considering bitcoin hadn't and still
hasn't been adopted widely as currency
were known as bitcoin 2.0 i love this
paragraph because it outlines just how
disconnected from reality the people
actually building cryptocurrencies
really are they don't understand
anything about the ecosystems they're
trying to disrupt they only know that
these are things that can be
conceptualized as valuable and assume
that because they understand one very
complicated thing programming with
cryptography that all other complicated
things must be lesser in complexity and
naturally lower in the hierarchy of
reality nails easily driven by the
hammer that they have created the idea
of putting medical records on a public
decentralized trustless blockchain is
absolutely nightmarish and anyone who
proposes it should be instantly
discredited the fact that rousseau fails
to question any of this is journalistic
malpractice
now in terms of improvements over
bitcoin ethereum has many it's not hard
bitcoin sucks in terms of problems with
bitcoin ethereum solves none of them and
introduces a whole new suite of problems
driven by the techno-fetishistic egotism
of assuming that programmers are
uniquely suited to solve society's
problems vitalik wants his invention to
be an infinite machine so let's ask what
that machine is built to do
in order to really understand the full
scope of this we do need to dig a bit
more into the technical aspects because
that technical functionality informs the
way that the rest of the system behaves
in a very mcluhanist way the machine
shapes the environment around it as
already mentioned a blockchain consists
of two broad fundamental components the
ledger and the consensus mechanism all
currently popular blockchains use an
append only ledger now this is on its
own not that remarkable append only is
just a database setting that only allows
new entries to be added to the end of
the current database once something is
written to the database it's read only
standard applications are typically
things like activity logs which is
conceptually all a blockchain really is
a giant log of transactions the hitch is
that it's decentralized with elective
participants hosting a complete copy of
the entire log and
this is where the second component comes
in the consensus mechanism all
validating participants called nodes
have a complete copy of the database and
no one copy is considered to be the
authoritative copy instead there is a
consensus mechanism that determines
which transactions actually happened
this is all the proof of work stuff
proof of work isn't the only consensus
mechanism but it's popular because it's
very easy to implement by just cloning
bitcoin and is resilient against the
kind of attacks that crypto enthusiasts
care about it's a very brute force
solution but legitimately if you want a
network of ledgers where no one trusts
anyone else just making everyone on the
network do extreme amounts of wasted
duplicate work is a solution one of the
major problems that this machine solves
is what's called the double spend
problem how do you stop someone from
spending the same dollar twice if
someone tries how do you determine which
transaction really happened banks solve
this problem by not correlating account
balance with any specific dollar
processing transactions first come first
serve which they track with central
resources and punishing users with
overdraft fees for double spending
eschewing a central solution
cryptocurrencies rely on their consensus
mechanism the most popular alternative
to proof of work is proof of stake where
validators post collateral of some kind
usually whatever currency is endemic to
the chain with the amount of collateral
determining their odds of being rewarded
the validation bounty for any given
transaction the main proposal of proof
of stake is that it significantly
reduces the wasted power problems of
proof of work but it's less resilient
than proof of work on the energy cost
side of things proof of stake is still
inefficient just by virtue of the sheer
volume of redundancy but on a per user
basis it's at least inefficient on the
scale of like
an mmo as opposed to a steel foundry
this is difficult to assess because the
most popular proof of stake chains are
still unpopular and low traffic in the
scope of things heavily centralized
claims about scalability are backed up
by nothing but the creator's word proof
of stake is also significantly more
complex because there now needs to be
some mechanism for determining who gets
to do the validations and also
determining how audits are conducted and
then the question of who has control
over that system and whether or not
someone can gain control of that system
or control over the whole stake by just
buying out the staking pool etc etc etc
proof of stake also even more explicitly
rewards the wealthy who have the capital
to both stake and spend it's also even
more explicitly exclusionary ethereum's
proposed proof-of-stake migration has a
buy-in of 32 ether which at the time of
writing is about 130 000
so really only early adopters and the
wealthy can actually meaningfully
participate for more than just crumbs
this is in turn compounding inherent
problems with the long-term growth of
the chain even if you solve the
escalating power requirements of
proof-of-work the data requirements of
storing the chain and participating as a
validator are also prohibitive in a way
that inevitably centralizes power in the
hands of a few wealthy operators 85
terabytes per year is actually it's
totally fine right like because uh 85
terabytes per year like if you have if
you have even one person that just keeps
buying like a hundred dollar hard drive
like i think once every month then they
can store it right like it's something
like that so it's too big for just like
a casual user that just wants to run the
chain on their laptop but one dedicated
user who cares but they can totally
afford to afford to store the chain um
so 85 terabytes not a big deal right but
once you crank that number higher there
comes a point at which it starts
becoming a really big deal the major
downside of all these systems is that
they're extremely slow proof of work is
inefficient by design and proof of stake
has multiple layers of lottery that need
to be executed before any transaction
can be conducted and in particular
suffers from delays when elected
validators are offline and the system
needs to draw again as an extension of
being slow they're also prone to getting
overwhelmed if too many people try to
make transactions simultaneously which
can cause desyncs between validators and
even lead to what's called a fork where
two or more pools of validators reach a
different consensus about the state of
the network and each branch keeps on
going afterwards assuming that it is the
authoritative version forks can also be
caused on purpose and this is in fact
the only way to effectively undo
transactions like if someone stole your
coins the only way to get them back
would be to convince the people who
manage the chain itself to negotiate a
rollback
that's foreshadowing for later now
because the nature of a fork involves a
disagreement on what transactions
actually happened and who got paid for
those transactions this means that each
arm of the fork has a vested interest in
its own arm being the authoritative arm
so resolving forks can turn into
irreconcilable schisms which is funny as
an outside observer viewing it as an
inane internet drama but is frankly
unacceptable for anything posturing as a
serious and legitimate currency like
it's important to stress that because of
the nature of the chain the way that the
id numbers of later blocks are dependent
on the outcomes of previous blocks these
aren't just a few disputed transactions
that need to be resolved between the
buyer the seller and the payment
processor these are disagreements on the
fundamental state of the entire economy
that create an entire alternate reality
it's an ecosystem that absolutely
demolishes consumer protections and
makes the re-implementation of them
extremely difficult one of the big
selling points of all this technology is
that it's particularly secure very
difficult for anyone to hack it directly
since there's so much redundancy a lot
of hay is made about the system's
resiliency against man in the middle
attacks which are your classic hollywood
hacker type attacks someone sends a
command from point a and on the way to
point b it is intercepted and altered
someone hacks into the bank and adds an
arbitrary number of zeros onto their
account balance evangelists will
commonly claim that blockchain could
revolutionize the global shipping
industry and reduce fraud it's a good
claim to interrogate first the things
that blockchain is capable of tracking
are things that manufacturers and
shippers are already tracking or at
least trying to track so this is not so
much revolution as it would be
standardization even that is built on a
predicate assumption that everyone picks
the same chain it's an extremely
optimistic assumption many many many
firms deliberately want their
information centralized and obfuscated
to protect against corporate espionage
the lack of a shared standardized bucket
to put all the information into is not
because it's been heretofore impossible
but because it's being undesirable
second it assumes the existence of a
theoretical mechanism that ensures the
synchronization of the chain and reality
above and beyond the current capacity of
logistics software some means of
preventing people from just lying to the
blockchain and giving it the information
it expects to be receiving the
blockchain equivalent of ripping off the
shipping label and slapping it on the
new box the bigger problem here is that
in the pantheon of fraud man in the
middle attacks are actually pretty rare
global shipping needs to deal with it in
certain capacities but taken on the
whole the vast majority of fraud doesn't
come from altering information as it
passes between parties rather from
colluding parties entering bad
information at the start con artists
don't hack the gibson to transfer your
funds to their offshore account they
convince you to give them your password
most fraud comes from people who
technically
have permission to be doing what they're
doing rather than preventing these
actual common types of fraud
cryptocurrency has made them absurdly
easy and the main reason why
cryptocurrency needs to be so resistant
to man in the middle attacks is because
the decentralized nature of the network
otherwise makes them acutely vulnerable
to those attacks what this all kind of
means is that blockchains are all pretty
bad at doing most of the things they're
trying to do and a lot of the
innovations in blockchains are attempts
at solving problems that blockchains
introduced the biggest issue that
cryptocurrencies have suffered from is a
lack of tangible things to actually use
them on as currencies renter food or
transit this is for pretty simple
reasons one is that the transaction fees
on popular chains are so prohibitive
that it's pointless to use them on any
transaction that isn't hundreds if not
thousands of dollars no one is going to
buy the bitcoin bucket from their local
kfc ethereum's main transaction fee
called gas on a good day runs around
twenty dollars u.s per transaction but
that's severely optimistic as of
december 2021 the daily average cost of
gas hasn't gone below 50 u.s since
august with the three-month daily
average riding over 130 dollars and
that's just the daily average the hourly
price can and does swing by up to two
orders of magnitude the throughput of
blockchains is so abysmal that
transaction slots are auctioned off to
the highest bidder that's why these
numbers are so extreme it only takes a
few high rollers competing on a
transaction to drive the hourly price of
gas up over a thousand dollars u.s the
internal term for this is a gas war
because it's just that common bots in
particular can drive gas prices well
into the tens of thousands of dollars as
they compete to capitalize on mistakes
such as someone listing something for
sale well below its general market price
also it needs to be stressed these gas
wars aren't localized to just the thing
that's being fought over if steam is
getting hammered because concerned ape
posted stardew valley 2 by surprise that
will probably stay pretty well contained
if taylor swift concert tickets go on
sale and livenation gets crushed you
might never even know what those don't
do is cause the cost of placing an order
on drive through rpg to spike by eight
thousand percent for three hours the
second big reason is that value on the
coins themselves is so volatile that
unless you're willing to engage with the
speculative nature of the coins there's
actually a huge risk in accepting them
as payment for anything bitcoin in
particular owing to its glacial
transaction times suffers from problems
where the value of the coin can change
dramatically between the start and end
of a transaction this is such a problem
that it's led to the rise of an entire
strata of middlemen in the ecosystem so
called stablecoin exchanges like tether
that exist to quickly transfer
cryptocurrencies between each other and
lock-in values the stable coins rather
than having a speculative value have a
value that's pegged to the value of an
actual currency like the euro or u.s
dollar the underlying problem that they
exist to solve is itself twofold one is
that converting cryptocurrency into
dollars is the step of the process that
makes you accountable to the tax man and
the primary goal of crypto in general is
to starve public services so that's a no
go the second is that there just aren't
actually that many buyers and there's
not enough liquidity in the ecosystem to
cash out big holdings tether the largest
stablecoin used to advertise itself as
being backed on a one-to-one basis back
when it was called realcoin but that
language has become far more nebulous
over time as it's become obvious that it
just isn't true this is a very
complicated situation but the short
version is that the people who own
tether also own a real money exchange
called bitfinex and there's evidence
that the two services both which require
having actual dollars on hand in order
to back their products and facilitate
exchanges are sharing the same pool of
money swapping it back and forth as
needed this means that at any given time
either service is potentially backed by
zero dollars or at least that's what the
data implies might be the case
point is that if you're a high roller
with hundreds of millions of conceptual
dollars tied up in cryptocurrency
there's a fundamental cash problem your
holdings have inflated to tens hundreds
or thousands of times what you put in
but that price is just theoretical it's
speculative you have all this crypto you
can't meaningfully spend it and there's
not enough buyers for you to get it out
in order for you to cash out you need to
convince someone else to buy in these
factors taken holistically mean that
cryptocurrency is a bigger full scam
there's a lot of digital ink spilt
trying to outline if it's a
decentralized ponzi scheme or a pyramid
scheme or some hybrid of the two which
is a taxonomical argument that i'm not
here to settle but like both of those
it's a bigger fool scam the whole thing
operates by buying worthless assets
believing that you will later be able to
sell them to a bigger fool the entire
structure of cryptocurrencies at their
basic level of operation is designed to
deliver the greatest rewards to the
earliest adopters regardless of if
you're talking about proof of work or
proof of stake this is inherent to their
being as steven deal put it these
schemes around crypto tokens cannot
create or destroy actual dollars they
can only shift them around if you sell
your crypto and make a profit in dollars
it's only because someone else bought it
at a higher price than you did and then
they expect to do the same and so on and
so on add infinitum every dollar that
comes out of cryptocurrency needs to
come from a later investor putting a
dollar in crypto investments cannot be
anything but a zero-sum game and many
are actually massively negative some in
order to presume a crypto investment
functions as a store of value we must
simultaneously need to suppose an
infinite chain of greater fools who keep
buying these assets at any irrational
price and into the future forever
all right with all that out of the way
let's talk about the ape in the room
nft super sexy mana always lures me i'm
too focused and you know you'll never
ever determine crypto astronaut dj
moving so hazardous crypto but i gonna
dabble uh open seas like chapel yeah
nfts
non-fungible tokens on a conceptual
level the tech acts as a sort of generic
database to mediate the exchange of
digital stuff the most optimistic read
on it is a framework for a type of
computer code that creates so-called
true digital objects meaning digital
objects that possess the attributes of
both physical objects and digital being
losslessly transmittable while providing
strict uniqueness which is an important
concept strict uniqueness is a way of
saying that two different things are
different things even if they're
different copies of the same thing
my copy of gray by e.l james is strictly
unique while millions of copies of the
book exist this is the only copy that is
this copy and this is the only copy that
has the very specific damage of being
glued shut and thrown into the bow river
it is also strictly scarce while
millions of copies of grey exist that's
still a finite number meaning it is
possible though not immediately
practical for the world to run out of
copies nfts impose a simulacrum of this
physical scarcity and uniqueness onto
digital objects within their ecosystem
on a technical level non-fungible token
is just a token that has a unique serial
number and can't be subdivided into
smaller parts two tokens even two that
tokenize the same conceptual thing are
still strictly unique with different
serial numbers within the context of
ethereum and its clones these tokens are
effectively a small packet of data that
can contain a payload of code it's a box
that you can put a micro program into
that micro program is called a smart
contract a name that is so comically
full of itself that i feel like it's
misleading to even call them that but i
have to for simplicity's sake but real
quick yes that is how the inventors
conceptualize the role of these things
as the unity of programming and law the
phrase code is law gets bandied about as
an aphorism and it's just so full of
holes that we're going to be spending
the next forever talking about it before
we move into that this is the root of it
there is a tremendous disconnect between
what nft advocates say they do and what
they actually do but and this is very
important both the claimed functionality
and the actual functionality are both
bad it's all broken none of it works
well so the idea of it becoming the norm
is terrible but the prospect of what the
world would look like if all the
mythologizing and over promising came
true
also super sucks the end goal of this
infant machine is the financialization
of everything any benefits of digital
uniqueness end up being a quirk a
necessary precondition of turning
everything into a stock market there's
nothing particularly offensive
underpinning the concept of digital
collectibles frameworks and subcultures
for forms of digital collectibles have
existed for decades within various
contexts but nfts exist to lend
credibility and functionality to the
cryptocurrencies that they exist on top
of okay okay
code is law now what that little smart
contract program does is up to the token
creator it can be a relatively
sophisticated applet that allows the
user to execute various commands or it
can be a plain hypertext link to a
static url of an image or anything in
between most are a lot closer to static
urls than they are to functional
programs this is in part because the
thing that nfts have become synonymous
with are digital artworks but really
what the token represents is arbitrary
it can be a video game item a permission
slip a subscription a domain name a
virus that steals all your digital stuff
or a combination of all of those well
the concept has been floating around
since 2015 when the framework was thrown
together in a day during a hackathon and
the first ethereum implemented tokens
were minted in 2017 for the mainstream
the story starts in the spring of 2021
following a string of high-priced sales
of tokens minted by digital artist
beeple culminating in a 69 million
dollar sale of a collage of people's
work in march via old money auction
house christies this high-profile sale
triggered a media frenzy and an online
gold rush as various minor internet
celebrities raced to cash in on the
trend hoping to be the next to cash out
big over the course of about six weeks
the ecosystem burnt through just about
every relevant meme possible elena
morris popularized on reddit as overly
attached girlfriends sold the original
screen grab to emirati music producer
farzenfarden fard for the equivalent of
a little over four hundred thousand
dollars u.s
zoe roth aka disaster girl sold the nft
of the original disaster girl photograph
to fard for also four hundred thousand
dollars kyle craven sold the original
bad luck brian photo for thirty six
thousand dollars to anonymous buyer at a
neand cat sold for almost six hundred
thousand dollars with multiple variants
also selling for six figures alice in
harvard sold creepy chan 1 and 2 for 67
and 83 000 respectively also both to
fard in addition to these high
high-profile sales of things that were
already popular whale buyers like fard
were dropping four and five-figure sales
onto a random assortment of other
artworks corporations and individuals
auctioned off nfts representing
intangible non-transferable concepts
like the first tweet or the first text
message cryptocurrency evangelists
jumped at every opportunity to
proselytize this new bold revolutionary
marketplace that would free artists from
the yoke of the gig economy and provide
buyers with an immutable record of
ownership of authenticated artwork
stored on an eternal distributed machine
you could be holding the next
generation's picasso artists could
continue to earn passive revenue from
secondary sales imagine what it'll be
worth in five years this created an
error of absolute mania as it seemed
like anything could be the golden ticket
digital artists especially those working
with media like generative art that's
difficult to monetize via conventional
channels like physical prints raced into
the space and on the whole
lost a lot of money critics began
questioning what it was that was
actually being bought and sold copyright
commercial permission a digital file
bragging rights in a huge number of
cases the answer wasn't very clear and
even the sellers caught in the promise
of a payday weren't all together sure
what they had even sold tons of the
tokens did little more than point to
images stored on normal servers readily
accessible via http meaning the bot
assets would be just as vulnerable to
link rod as anything else some pointed
to images stored on peer-to-peer ipfs
servers which are more resistant to link
rot as similar to a torrent it only
requires that someone keep the file
active somewhere rather than requiring
the original server to stay up but as
millions of dead torrents prove that's
still a far cry from the eternal storage
solution that evangelists were claiming
the images were stored and delivered the
same way as any other image on the
internet easily saved or duplicated
simply by virtue of the fact that in
order for your computer to display an
image it needs to download it claims of
digital scarcity apply only to the token
itself not the thing the token signified
more than that there was no
cryptographic relationship between the
image and the tokens the image
associated with a token could be easily
altered or replaced if the person with
access to the server that the image was
hosted on just
changed file names making the
relationship between the two tenuous and
flimsy in a way that undermined the
claims that this was somehow a more
durable reliable way of transacting
digital art there was also no root proof
of authenticity no confirmation that the
person minting the artwork was the
person who created the artwork this is a
pretty handy encapsulation of the way
that blockchain fails to solve the most
common problems with fraud which tend to
start with bad data going into a system
at the input not data being altered
mid-stream artists who complained about
this system which clearly incentivized
impersonating popular artists including
deceased artists were told that it was
their fault for not jumping in sooner
that if they had bought in and minted
their stuff first then it would have
been easy to prove the forgeries because
evangelists don't see this as a tool as
a market that may or may not fit into an
artist's business they see it as the
future so failure to participate isn't a
business decision it's just a mistake
they're terrible people all told the
frenzy collapsed pretty quickly by june
the market had already receded by about
which incidentally just further
incentivized the low effort process of
minting other people's artwork to the
point that art platform deviantart
implemented an extremely well received
feature that scans several popular nft
marketplaces for matching images
the output of that is extremely
depressing
not to labor the point but reposting
digital art without attribution is
nothing new profiting off someone else's
art is also nothing new all that's new
is nfts represent a high energy
marketplace with an irrational pricing
culture where the main buyer is easily
flattered and not particularly
discerning the potential payoff is
extremely high much much higher than a
bootleg red bubble store the
consequences border on non-existent and
the market is clearly in an untenable
state so there's an incentive to get in
at as low a cost as possible before it
collapses hence the absolute plague of
art theft even the argument that artists
could make passive revenue off secondary
sales turned out to have a lot of
caveats attached one the smart contract
for the token needs to have a function
that defines royalties so anyone who
minted a token based off of hype making
it sound like an inherent function of
the system was out of luck and two the
token doesn't know what a sale is and
can't differentiate between being sold
and being transferred so it's actually
the marketplace that informs the token
you're being sold and collects the
royalties end result royalties are
easily bypassed simply by using a
marketplace that doesn't collect
royalties or uses a different format of
royalty collection that's incompatible
with the function the token uses while a
few sellers legitimate and otherwise
made off with undeniably big paydays
hundreds of thousands of artists bought
in only to find that there wasn't a new
revolutionary highly trafficked audience
of digital art collectors instead there
was a closed market dealing in casino
chips where the primary winners were
those already connected who already had
the means to get the attention of the
whales in the media a market where
participation required buying into a
cryptocurrency at a rapidly fluctuating
price in order to pay the minting costs
to post the work where it would sit
unsold this left those artists in the
lurch where they had to choose between
just eating the losses or attempting to
convince their existing audience to buy
in as well the people who actually won
were the people with large holdings of
cryptocurrency specifically ethereum
which mediated the vast majority of
these big ticket purchases david gerard
author of attack of the 50-foot
blockchain summarized it on his blog
very succinctly as such nfts are
entirely for the benefit of the crypto
grifters the only purpose the artists
serve is as aspiring suckers to pump the
concept of crypto and of course to buy
cryptocurrency to pay for minting nfts
sometimes the artist gets some crumbs to
keep them pumping the concept of crypto
the rush benefits them in two ways first
the price of ether itself goes up
directly from the spike in demand
between january and may the price of
ether rose from seven hundred dollars to
four thousand dollars and second there's
new actual buyers who aren't just
trading bitcoin for tether for ether and
back again but are buying in with
dollars providing the whole system with
the liquidity needed for wales to
actually cash out this arrangement
needing to buy a highly volatile coin
from people who paid far far less for it
in order to participate in a market that
they control is why people reflexively
describe the whole arrangement as a scam
if you buy in at four thousand dollars
and compete against people who bought in
at four dollars you're the sucker it
reveals the basic truth that these
aren't marketplaces they're casinos and
indeed even through all the rhetoric of
protecting artists and whatnot was the
ever-present specter of the gamble
whatever you buy now might be worth
hundreds of times more later constantly
invoked as the opposite proposition of
the bad deal what if you had been the
person who bought in at four dollars
let's take a closer look at that eye
watering 69 million dollar beeple sale
independent journalist amy caster has
done an enviable job running down the
details here in her piece medecovin the
mystery beeple art buyer and his nft
defy scheme but to summarize the long
and short of her notes the buyer is a
crypto entrepreneur named vingnesh
cinderezin who purchased the piece to
boost the reputation and value of his
own crypto investment scheme metapurse
and metapurse's own token b20 which
beeple owns 2 percent of the total
supply of following the christie's sale
the reported value of b20 went from 36
cents per token to 23
and that's just the anatomy of a single
sale the very obvious conclusion
observers reached was that none of this
is about the art at all but the
speculative value not what it's worth to
you but what it'll potentially be worth
in the future to someone else it's not a
market it's a casino gambling on the
receipt for an image or video that
otherwise infinitely digitally
replicable the thing itself is
immaterial as long as it can make a line
go up this is the essence of the market
and a microcosm of what evangelists
imagine they want to see as the future
the financialization of everything the
frenzied market around old reddit memes
was doomed from the start there's a
finite supply of meaningful originals so
to keep this thing going to keep the
line going up you need something more
something less tied to anything specific
sir
the lambo is ready
what
in the months since the initial craze
the marketplace had mutated the it thing
was no longer memes or digital works
from established artists but character
profiles from large procedurally
generated collections with names like
crypto punks board ape yacht club lazy
lions cool cats ether gals gator world
baby llama club magic mushroom club
rogue society bot and crypto chicks
these were notable for again commanding
utterly irrational prices seemingly
completely decoupled from any legitimate
or legal transaction and being
generally extremely fugly this surge
generated an immediately adversarial
relationship between the buyers who
touted them as both evidence of their
extravagant wealth and their foresight
into the future of digital economies and
pretty much everyone else a very common
response to anyone using one of these
profile pics or bragging about their
purchase became saving and reposting the
image in reply or even changing profile
pics to match
spurred by a speculative tweet from
twitter developers suggesting that they
were working on an nft verification
system twitter users broadly rallied at
the opportunity to immediately identify
people that it was okay to bully tweets
from within the cryptosphere started
leaking out things like santiago santos
tweeting things like nfts equal identity
2.0 can't remember the last time i used
my pick on the left emphasis on physical
traits genetic lottery prone to bias and
prejudice identity by choice unique and
digitally scarce representation of
values and beliefs
of course what santiago was leaving out
was that he had paid the equivalent of
171 thousand dollars u.s for that
profile pick which
probably gives him some incentive to
really commit to it as something
interesting and special even though
stripped to the studs
literally all he was describing was
using a
non-representational image as a profile
pic for about six years my profile on
the dungeons and dragons forums was a
stock photo of a cabbage
so
not really breaking new ground here greg
eisenberg sat at his computer and
decided to bang out most people who make
fun of nfts own zero nfts have never
minted an nft have never participated in
a community have never staked their nft
haven't built on top of an nft project
have never earned an nft playing a game
missed out on bake punks cool cats etc a
chain of logic implying that skeptics of
the market are just uninformed sore
losers incidents like these lent to the
very accurate perception that the
loudest voices in nfts weren't very
familiar with internet culture as a
whole weren't terribly smart in general
and were by and large coming at all this
from the financial side further
supported by all of them having tweets
or not investment advice in their
twitter bios in short the same people
who made and bought juicero
what is this
it's a juicero
it also laid bare that the conversations
were inherently suspect how can you ever
trust the sincerity of someone telling
you how awesome their 171 thousand
dollar investment is when your
persuasion stands to directly benefit
them by potentially driving up the value
of their investment portfolio you've got
to be extremely rich for a hundred and
seventy one thousand dollars to not be
an extremely sunk cost and that's
absolutely going to weigh on your mind
and influence how you see the market so
for my part i tweeted about several of
these incidences and was in response
hounded for days by annoying people with
nft profile pics who insisted that i
just didn't get it i wasn't seeing the
community so i decided to go see the
community my experiment started with the
cool cats discord one of the communities
that i've been assured was top of the
pile i joined read back through days and
days of conversation logs watched the
active conversations and was
generally unimpressed it was at best
unremarkable a primary concern was still
rooted in the monetary value of the
tokens if you spend 1 million on a cat
it's not just for twitter and no one
would be happy seeing someone mint
another one later for free that's why
punks are at 120 eath symbols memes
there's the value
what wasn't unremarkable is the way that
i was immediately deluged by bots
sending me invites to other discords so
between the spam i was receiving and the
cool cat's dedicated shill channel
i came up with an idea
rap crypto y'all know bitcoin i want to
thank y'all for checking out this joint
see i'm vandal the token rapper and this
right here is a brand new chapter follow
me as i go rambo
to the moon in my brand new lambo
for days now i've been accepting every
spam nft discord invite i've received
and it's getting dire stoner cat's oni
ronan magic mushroom club nf tits the
humanoids ether gals cool cats senzu
seeds pro camel riders long wien clubs
stick humans bumping uglies world of woe
jack gen map dimes magic marbles nft
beverly hills car club cash cows long
neck cartel pug force hood punks gorilla
club alien archives betting buddhas
fighting turtle club the iconimals
basement dwellers wizard man jenkins
cotty medemons crazy skulls box gang gym
punks uncovered nitro punk crypto bowls
masquerade massacre cat colony skeletees
daffy panda ganging up bedding kongs
wolves of wall street happy sharks tea
cup pigs cool llamas mad carrot gang
barnyard fashionistas soul cities oink
club outlaw punks crypto astronauts nft
worlds panda paradise time travelers
cyber kongs party 8 billionaire club j
corps cryptocados meta birds and that's
about as far as i got before more or
less giving up and finally shutting off
discord dms now this is a fraction of a
fraction of what's out there but i do
think it's a pretty representative
sample and i learned a lot for example
the basic psychological profile of the
average buyer is someone who is
tenuously middle class socially isolated
and highly responsive to memes they are
someone who has very little experience
with real businesses and production
processes thus are unlikely to be turned
off by unrealistic claims about future
returns they are insecure about their
lack of knowledge and this makes them
very susceptible to flattery in
particular being assured that the only
reason for negativity is because critics
just don't understand what they
understand
being tenuously middle class gives them
enough disposable income to engage with
a pretty expensive system but also a
very potent anxiety about their
financial future it goes without saying
that they're fixated on money and they
principally understand the technology as
a means of making money criticism of the
system is typically met with confusion
don't you want to make money i also
learned a lot about fraud and how to do
it both on purpose and by accident the
term rug pull with its derivations rug
and rugged all to describe projects that
made big promises but then took the
money and ran embedded themselves in my
vocabulary extremely quickly the market
is just absolutely lousy with fraud and
deception wash trading where you sell
something to your own sock puppets in
order to lure in real buyers who think
they're getting a good deal is rampant
market manipulation is so common and
accepted that it's actually considered
bad form if project leaders don't
actively engage in it like it's
considered disrespectful to the buyers
if the project leaders don't help them
inflate the resale price also and i
really should not leave this merely
implied the art is bad but not in any
sort of interesting way it's bad in a
smoothed over copycat way a low effort
garbage dump from artists who have
largely given up on having ideas or
opinions derivative lazy ugly hollow and
boring the capacity for original thought
long having been drained out of the
illustrators kept in the employ and
proximity of people who refused to shut
up about cryptocurrency there is an
overwhelming tendency to fall back on
stale memes and self-flattery a massive
volume of cryptocurrency art ends up
being art about cryptocurrency
transparent pandering to an audience
that is either deeply stupid or easily
pleased and quite possibly both absent
any artistic insight the vacuum is
instead felt overflowing with references
to doge memes bitcoin ethereum stonks to
the moon by the dip good morning and
desperate pleas for senpai elon musk to
notice them all presented with the
earnestness and authenticity of a pickle
rick bong it's tempting to say that my
approach accepting every spam invite was
a really flawed way to delve deeper that
obviously accepting invites from spam
bots would mainly lead me into less
stable projects but surprisingly no i
got just as much spam for successful
projects as humanoids and nft worlds as
i did for rug pulls like crypto
astronauts and hood punks on the whole
if you just look at the pitch package
and the sample product there's very
little material difference between a
project that's gonna sell out ten
thousand tokens in six hours and one
that's going to become a trash fire as
the project leader has a nervous
breakdown and burns them in three days
post launch after only selling 800
tokens party a billionaire club sold out
bringing in about 3.2 million dollars
and are now flexing their wealth by
partnering with other crypto projects
like the two chains produced nft cartoon
show the red ape family which is just
really truly shows off the community's
deep pockets and commitment to quality
deep in their roadmap is the promise
that they will start production on an
mmorpg a claim that buyers are entirely
faithful in crypto astronauts sold
1262 of their
9485 tokens bringing in an impressive
375 thousand dollars but as nice as that
number is it's not remotely enough to
even start proceeding on their plan to
build a full-scale pvp-based mmo
following the failed mint in october the
devs slowly went quiet and then bit by
bit websites social media accounts and
eventually the discord itself all
disappeared based off the ostensible
product why should one of these succeed
and the other fail the key distinction
ultimately between a party a billionaire
club and a crypto astronauts is that
pabc was already flush with cash and
able to manufacture hype with high
priced giveaways and expensive
advertising buying advertising space in
times square in particular is a specific
fixation but running a 10 second ad
every 8 minutes on one out of the way
billboard in times square isn't
effective advertising not externally all
it's really good for is internal
propaganda making insiders feel like the
money that they've spent is buying
credibility and if you're in a
speculative bubble betting that someone
down the line will buy you out for more
than you bought in
credibility is worth everything in the
world most game devs would hesitate to
post this to twitter they posted it to
times square
this is pervasive even in the most
established projects ones that have been
going for years there's not really an
underlying
thing these aren't fandoms in the way
that you would experience them around a
game or a tv show or a book the product
is pretty insubstantial if not
functionally non-existent this is where
these projects diverge significantly
from the artworks that drove the
speculative mania in the spring they're
not positioning themselves as art that's
worth possessing for the art as flimsy
and illusory as that claim was but as
ongoing projects that you buy into the
purchase of a token is an abstracted
version of buying early stock in a
company a venture capital style
investment in promises which is a very
significant mutation okay so what do
these phantom companies claim to exist
to do
pretty much all of them promise direct
financial returns in some way shape or
form sometimes this is just a nebulous
sense that the whole thing will go to
the moon meaning the value of the tokens
will take off unless early buyers will
be able to resell for huge profits or
more direct as the project leaders
promise the formation of effectively an
unofficial hedge fund investing a
communal pool into other crypto products
probably the funniest of all of these
was betting kongs which wanted to create
an unregistered real money casino in
which token holders would be explicitly
part owners and also permitted to gamble
in the casino that they owned betting
kongs is not your ordinary nft project
we need to create passive income for nft
owners by co-owning a casino with a
profit split welcome to the white paper
fellow gamblers why are we doing this to
put it short we love gambling and we
noticed how a lot of the operators out
there are owned by large corporations
who have no care for the community or
the service they provide we want to
provide a project where everyone playing
can be a co-owner of the place they're
playing at and make money from it all
failure was probably the best outcome
for everyone here if we're being honest
some promise this in the form of a more
conventional media project like a comic
book or a cartoon or a movie or all of
the above
we have planned the creation of a series
of comics dedicated to the pixel girl
the key image is static or at least we
think so now but the squeaky girl is
still a seductress so the image of
breasts will be presented in various
variations that our community will
approve
let's imagine there are 5 000 nf tits
holders there is a 30 million market of
comics lovers in the u.s on average
every comics lover spends around 20 usd
per comic per week it means 80 dollars
per month and 960 dollars per year
the total addressable market is worth 28
billion 800
million usd let's imagine we take one
percent of this market it's
million usd
per
year on the base of monthly
subscriptions raised in crypto this is a
cash flow
nice to see some active communication
and appreciate the effort as announced
this afternoon trying to resurrect this
project into something successful the
only thing i would like to see assuming
the project can be successfully turned
around is to perhaps in addition to some
revenue sharing have some revenue
donated to breast cancer research to
truly enjoy them we should keep them
happy and healthy as already implied
many of them promise video games often
an mmo but just as often like
just
the concept of a video game
okay wait let me word that another way
they will promise a video game like
that's the promise in its entirety no
clues for genre style scope engine or
platform or how any of the tokens would
interact with it just a video game if we
sell 10 000 tokens for 300 each we will
start brainstorming development ideas
for a video game now all of these tend
to be in collections of 10 000 and
there's actually an interesting sort of
quirk inside that the initial format was
to mint an entire collection and just
shove them out onto the market the cap
comes into play purely because you have
to tell the program generating the
garbage when to stop however as the
scheme started to take off and
competition rose it became obvious that
this was a sucker's way of doing it
because that meant paying gas fees on
everything up front so someone came up
with a system for minting a random
output on demand which shuffles the mint
cost off onto the buyer from there it
all took off like wildfire very low
upfront cost extremely low risk plus it
turns the entire system into a gotcha
game with different rarity curves for
attributes at best these are all
obfuscated gambling schemes at worst
active scams and the payoff of failure
makes it extremely difficult to parse
one of those from the other world of
wojak only sold 20 tokens to 11 people
and still pocketed over 5 thousand
dollars pro camel riders sold 114 tokens
to 71 buyers and took home 25 000
metamon sold 722 of their 9999 tokens to
343 buyers and walked off with 211 000
since the average buy-in is over 350
bucks the payday for failure makes it
irrational to succeed the interesting
aspect of it all though is the emergent
fiction of it these smoke vendors don't
have an actual product more complex than
the output of a vending machine in the
front of a grocery store so they need a
story to sell instead and so we get this
wave of poorly defined projects pitching
a token with an attached jpeg that
represents the concept of a thing that
could become a future business what that
business does is unimportant and indeed
many of these projects successful and
otherwise trade in a flattering myth of
decentralization where the direction of
the business down to its fundamental
product is shunted into the
indeterminate future to be decided later
by collective consensus are we a comic
book a movie a hedge fund a casino or a
bi-monthly curated box of snacks well
that's for the token holders to decide
all that matters is that whatever it is
it will definitely make the value of
your tokens go up so you should
definitely buy two
one thing i learned about nfts if you
think something's gonna be a blue chip
you should definitely buy at least two
because you're gonna get one emotionally
attached to one of them
and you're not going to want to sell it
because nfts are going to explode all
over the world and if you've got a blue
chip today it's going to be incredibly
more valuable in five years from now or
even three years from now or even two
years from now than it is today on the
front of otherwise respectable or at
least established brands and people
getting into nfts the results tend to be
extremely tepid and insubstantial even
by the standards of nfts very low risk
low quality low engagement tokens
shoveled out the door to capitalize on a
hot buzzword chasing the cash that's
sloshing around
tied up in all this there's an extremely
pervasive resistance to any form of
skepticism that ultimately manifests as
a sort of toxic positivity this is all
part of a complex feedback loop the
projects broadly speaking lack any kind
of substantial product existing almost
entirely as promises backed by nothing
more than a screenshot of a road map and
some sample pfps and again i think it's
really important to keep in mind that
that goes for successful projects just
as much as for rug pulls there really
isn't any meaningful difference between
a party ape billionaire club and a
betting kongs betting kongs were never
going to make a casino even if they
hadn't tanked and despite the fact that
they were running billboards in times
square pabc is never making an mmorpg
both claims are equally ridiculous but
one of the two made a huge pile of money
the primary product is ultimately hype
which is both insubstantial and fickle
negativity both internal and external
can have a meaningful impact on the
willingness of people to buy into a
project and if buyers are tepid then you
won't get a runaway sale and if you
don't get a runaway sale then that's
going to turn off buyers even more which
means the secondary market for tokens
will likely fail to materialize
this is what makes enthusiasts so deeply
unreliable they have meaningful
financial stakes in an intangible
volatile thing that exists entirely as a
collective idioform a story about a
potential future outcome whose value is
based entirely on public perception you
can't trust what they have to say
because they're currently holding a hot
potato and as much as they insist that
they just really really enjoy the
feeling of a burning hot potato in their
hands
do they or are they just hoping that
you'll catch it this creates an
environment of toxic positivity where
doubt is aggressively policed by both
project leaders who have an obvious
financial interest in hype since their
big payday is the minting rush and
community members themselves who have a
speculative financial interest in hype
while all of that is logical in the pure
sense that there is an effect that can
be explained by an incentive the output
is effectively a self-organizing high
control group doubters are ostracized so
aggressively that it chills all
conversation about a project's actual
viability all concerns are just fud fear
uncertainty and doubt questions that
would be utterly banal in any other
investment forum what has the team done
what assets do they have why should
anyone believe that they can deliver on
their promises are treated as hostile
and the frank reality is because there
aren't answers party a billionaire club
is just as vaporous and yet they
superficially succeeded so there's
incentive to enforce the collective
illusion this is multiplied by an
internal form of performative etiquette
participants ritualistically wish each
other good morning and good night boiled
down to the shorthand gm and gn that
seems like a small thing there's nothing
inherently suspicious about good morning
or good night but in observed practice
it's a very distinct ritual not merely a
shibboleth but a repetitive action that
signals in-group membership and affirms
loyalty on an ongoing basis if you have
diamond hands it means you're willing to
hold a token until some promised future
where the value goes to the moon you're
not a paper hands loser who is easily
spooked by instability volatility or the
fact that there's no reason to believe
that anyone is ever going to want to buy
a crypto astronaut in the future the
shorthand wagmi we're all going to make
it is aphoristically bandied about even
in openly zero sum competitions where by
definition most participants explicitly
won't make it but you can't point that
out because that would be fud and if
you're spreading fud then you're ngmi
not gonna make it and making it getting
rich is all that matters hfsp
have fun staying poor
these are synthesized into a no true
scotsman paradigm the we in we're all
going to make it does not refer to we
all it refers to the select the chosen
the diamond hands and the hodlers those
who make it are clearly the we and if
you didn't make it then you weren't
people who get angry about being scammed
by a rug poll or by malware or by social
engineering are berated and belittled
for not following the crowd this
incubates a community trained to ignore
warning signs and dismiss criticism a
community with internal language and
customs that are explicitly incompatible
with outside communications skepticism
is fud from non-believers who are trying
to undermine the value of your assets
and manipulate a crash or trick you into
being a paper hands it all maps onto
narratives of sin and deception a chosen
few who are privileged with advanced
knowledge about the promised land which
they can achieve by holding strong to
the rituals and expelling all doubt the
end product is a self-organizing high
control group and the results of that
are obvious there are still people
convinced that somehow someone is going
to pick up the ashes of evolved apes and
manifest the rest of the project a
belief based on no observable evidence
you like the ban you like to ban people
right you like to ban people from your
twitch stream huh people all you're
doing is [ __ ] on the central ambrose
yeah i'm sorry you don't like to make
money here and to network but uh
i wanted to talk on your twitch stream
man i probably could have brought a lot
of people on there and all you want to
do is talk [ __ ] and ban people man you
ban me instantly
so the question then is what do the
tokens
actually do
as mentioned before the token itself is
just a box that a bit of data can be put
into now this box is extremely small to
the point that even an average cell
phone photograph is several times too
large to fit due to the nature of the
chain updating software that's put onto
the chain is both difficult and
expensive complicated programs need to
be broken up into multiple tokens each
containing a smart contract that defines
a portion of the whole and all of these
contracts need to interlink and
reference each other but with an eye
towards the fact that each transaction
that either computes or alters
information requires paying processing
fees only
reading information is free the process
of fixing a bug in a smart contract
basically amounts to minting a new copy
of the contract and then jumping through
some hoops to rename the old and new
contracts so that the new copy has the
name that any other interacting
contracts are looking for paying fees
for just about every step of that
process this creates a very funny
catch-22 where on one hand is the
insistence that the nfts that end users
buy are potentially extremely powerful
able to be miniature self-governing
applets that exist in a web of like
applets and on the other hand is a large
stack of incentives to put as little
into them as possible for an example of
the pitfalls wolf game was a somewhat
popular nft based gambling game that
bragged about being hosted entirely on
chain at great expense everything from
the pixel art wolves and sheep to the
game's code was stored on ethereum the
idea behind the game is that users would
mint a character token which had a 90
chance of being a sheep and a 10 chance
of being a wolf with a finite supply of
wolves and sheep available the important
thing here is that the character tokens
weren't just a bit of art and a serial
number but tiny programs that allowed
users to perform interactions like
staking the problem is that their code
was full of multiple bugs and since some
of those bugs were contained in the
character tokens they were replicated
across all 13
809 minted tokens
a glitchy token can't be patched it must
be
replaced so the wolf game devs were
forced to not only redeploy all their
contracts but attempt to remint and
distribute identical copies of every
token
generated it didn't go well
given the risks inherent in putting
functionality inside the token itself
and the high cost of interaction the
most common application is to use
external systems to simply check for
possession of a token this is where we
introduce another player into the
ecosystem wallet managers like metamask
in a few short years the system has
already grown so bloated and difficult
to interact with that it's become
necessary to develop middleware
applications that simplify the process
of generating wallets switching wallets
and mediating handshakes between the
wallet and external systems from one
point of view these wallet managers are
the golden key that makes it all work
they solve the single sign-on problem
allowing your web browser to simply know
that it's you who is using it
automatically negotiating permissions
based on relevant tokens it's your login
your credit card your steam profile and
your bank account all rolled into a
single point of contact making
interaction with web 3 the internet of
the future
frictionless from another point of view
it's a massive point of failure that
contains so much information so many
permissions so much of worth that it
becomes an extremely obvious point of
attack manufactured by idiots who claim
to be building a security product in
2021 that doesn't obfuscate key phrases
within the ui or use two-factor
authentication remember again that these
people want to put medical records
driver's licenses professional
accreditations and real estate deeds
into their system they should not be
trusted the entire market is absolutely
lousy with scams and has been since
bitcoin first gained any traction every
single scam structure imaginable has
been dusted off and redeployed into this
explicitly unregulated market where
victims are largely without recourse
these range from institutional scams
like ponzi schemes pump and dumps and
insider trading to middleweight scams
like gold brick and wash trading to
grittier scams like phishing and sending
fake links pump and dumps in particular
are conducted in broad daylight since
it's not illegal it's just against the
terms of service of the exchanges that
you use to do it so the worst case
scenario is you burn your account
they'll straight up walk you through the
process of doing a pump and dump no code
words diagrams and everything they're
notable as they're actually a two-headed
scam because you see you might get
recruited onto the pump half of the
scheme or you might
think you're being recruited to pump but
you're actually the dump as already
mentioned blockchain is resilient to
direct man-in-the-middle attacks or
someone tries to inject bad data
straight into the chain but
man-in-the-middle attacks are rare in an
environment like cryptocurrency with few
if any repercussions for misbehavior
that stays within the cryptosphere
man-in-the-middle attacks are wholly
unnecessary why try to brute force your
bad data onto the chain when you can
trick someone into giving you access to
their wallet then transfer all their
stuff out every smart contract becomes a
self-rewarding bug bounty where the
payout is whatever apes and coins you
can grab before anyone notices and
that's not even touching on the subject
of malware smart contracts are just code
there's software there's no reason they
can't be viruses or worms the primary
limitation is processing power but also
it's a virus that someone can drop
directly into your bankless bank account
and just wait for you to activate it and
yeah that's right there's no offer
confirmation step in sending tokens back
and forth someone who knows your wallet
can just drop stuff right into it so
like
pin that somewhere in your brain the
best part about this is that the whole
ecosystem operates on a strict
assumption that possession is ownership
and access is permission which is
absolutely buckwild coming from software
developers claim to be very concerned
with system security if someone tricks
you into sending them your board ape
it's now theirs the only mechanism in
the machine for parsing legitimate
transactions from illegitimate
transactions is the consensus mechanism
which is only concerned with whether or
not the transactions followed the rules
of the software the only illegitimacy it
recognizes are people trying to insert
fake data when you are tricked into
doing something all of the mechanics of
what follows are by the rules of the
system
legitimate it's a legal transfer more
relevant however is the sheer density of
these scams the one market that
cryptocurrency has successfully
disrupted is the market of fraud think
of it this way a big population of
people have willingly self-identified
that they have substantial disposable
income poor judgment low social literacy
a high tolerance for nonsensical risk
and are highly persuadable people who
fall victim to these scams have
basically no options other than taking
to social media and attempting to whip
up enough of a frenzy that they can
convince marketplaces like openc to act
as de facto sensors by delisting stolen
tokens there's no authority you can
report them to that has the power to
return your tokens the best you can hope
for is denying the scammers profit on
their incredibly low cost operation if
your business is tricking people out of
their money you would be a fool if you
didn't take the opportunity not only
have participants advertise their
susceptibility to incoherent promises of
future returns the immutable structure
of the chain the persistence of data and
the ease with which that data can be
collated
means that for scammers it's extremely
easy to find marks every discord for a
rug pull nft project is a roster of
potential victims the ledger of
bakeholders is a shopping list of
targets the twitter account of anyone
complaining about what they lost on
evolved apes is the low-hanging fruit of
a very ripe orchard and that's a pretty
good segue into talking about privacy
issues
a low trust environment is also a low
privacy environment anything you do on a
blockchain is by design accessible to
everyone who knows how to navigate the
data now you might be thinking isn't
that the opposite of how it's supposed
to work
i thought crypto was all anonymous
so
yes crypto is anonymous by default
there's no inherent requirement for
proof of identity and in fact numerous
applications that would benefit from a
stricter one-to-one correlation between
accounts and people struggle with this
on forums and social media it's called
sock puppeting in crypto it's called a
sybil attack where users are able to
generate numerous alternate identities
by creating additional accounts or
wallets the epidemic of wash trading on
openc relies on the ability to pretend
you're several different people as you
buy apes from yourself for hundreds of
thousands of dollars rather than
anonymous this is pseudonymous everyone
can see what wallets and contracts your
wallet interacts with based off the long
hash addresses like this but that hash
is only implicitly connected to your
identity based on circumstantial
connections of course a big
circumstantial connection would be
something like registering with a crypto
based social action platform that
intrinsically connects the two this
makes it pretty easy to see that lana
morris overly attached girlfriend paid
153 dollars on march 31st to mint the
overly attached girlfriend nft followed
by a 205 reserve on april 2nd to list
the nft on foundation ethereum whale
farsen fardenfard then bought the token
on april 3rd for 200 ethereum 30 of
which went to foundation with laina
getting the remaining 170 which she
transferred into usd using the exchange
service kraken in a block of 105 on
april 4 and a block of 65 on april 22nd
for a combined total payout of 374
after her sale zoe roth transferred the
ethereum to dollars via coinbase the
next day and hasn't touched the wallet
since kyle craven minted several
other tokens but for the most part just
split the ethereum from the initial sale
into two separate holding wallets where
it sat untouched since
you don't need to be some super hacker
to figure this stuff out it's all
publicly available that's the entire
point of the system and in another
feature not bug arrangement remember
nothing can be deleted from the
blockchain without tremendous effort now
that's fine if the blockchain only
contains a contextually relevant log of
transactions there are absolutely
contexts where that level of
transparency is desirable but that falls
apart when you start talking about using
the blockchain itself as the storage
medium for
like an entire social network blockchain
based social network scuttlebutt seems
tacitly aware that this is a bad idea
like somewhere inside their human brains
they recognize that it might be a
mistake to make it impossible to remove
things from the system when they warn
users that anyone willing to dig can
surface any old usernames photos and
bios but that doesn't actually give them
pause so
if someone posts say child abuse imagery
revenge porn your home address intimate
details of your private life there's
just nothing you can really do about
that if you mistakenly over share post
some information that maybe you
shouldn't have it's already too late you
can try to hide it but you can't delete
it remember that if someone knows your
wallet address they can just put tokens
directly into it as alluded there's a
whole scam where you drop someone at nft
that lifts the art from who cares
somewhere but the smart contract is
malicious code that drains their wallet
if they ever interact with it to move it
sell it stake it burn it it just becomes
a landmine sitting in their wallet
forever yo this is fake this is fake
this is fake this is fake they popped up
in my wallet i clicked on it to delete
it immediately they stole 19 grand
happily i just started this wallet but
they already stole 19 out of it need
[ __ ] help immediately even on the
non-malware side of things people have
already been using this to dump
promotional tokens into the wallets of
celebrities and influencers but you know
dick pics are an any second now kind of
thing right oh look i minted a photo of
your front door and dropped it directly
into your wallet and you can't just like
delete it you need to actively send it
somewhere and pay gas fees to do so
revolutionary new vectors and harassment
the end product here is a massive power
imbalance that's baked into the fabric
of how you engage with this new world
order users who engage with the system
authentically as themselves expose vast
swathes of information about themselves
and their activities while users who
engage disingenuously are empowered in
their ability to deceive defraud and
disappear a lot of this rhetoric stems
from a pretty deep failure to understand
what a central authority really is or
that you can decentralize data storage
while centralizing data ethereum is
ultimately a central platform and the
fact that a few dozen people need to
sign off on every major change before it
can be implemented is largely
meaningless and symbolic with the
validation network ultimately sitting
somewhere between consortium and cartel
every large platform has multiple
internal and external stakeholders that
form a consensus about the direction of
the platform windows is not a
single-minded monolith apple issues
voting shares google is basically a
hydra while the network of ethereum
miners and validators are not a formal
corporation
yet there's no mechanism in existence
that compels them to act in the interest
of users particularly poor and
disempowered users where those interests
conflict with their own the movement of
ethereum from proof of work to proof of
stake has been vaporware in no small
part because the validators simply
choose not to because proof of work
volatility and high gas fees benefit
them in the here and now while proof of
stake and low gas fees only benefit them
in a hypothetical future because these
extremely obvious pitfalls are what you
get when you let guys like vitalik
buterin and elon musk design the future
the sole protection for users of
ethereum is that the system is so
cumbersome that all but the most
egregious breaches aren't worth
addressing of course that in truth means
that only the wealthy have access to
justice within the system if you take
all these different things all these
parts of your identity all your economic
activity all the video games you play
all the groups you join and stick them
into one system that's a central system
it doesn't matter how many different
servers that system spans or how many
validators need to agree before changes
can be made you've pooled all that data
in one place the proposed web 3 crypto
driven future of the internet is a
privacy disaster this is why i find
metamask horrifying as a product it's a
bucket that's asking you to pour
unfathomable amounts of data and
permissions into it it's such a
tremendous and monumental point of
failure and this is where nfts really
bloom into their final form
the primary use case of tokens beyond
speculation ultimately is to function as
access passes from a web engineering
perspective imagine tokens that are the
mother of all cookies and consider a
tracking token that users don't just
willingly associate themselves with but
enthusiastically drag with them from
device to device ensuring a continuity
of tracking across all web activity the
future version of the web built on the
back of cryptocurrency and mediated by
financialized tokens is a dystopia it's
a technology that's built to turn
everything into money to treat every
corner of our social existence as a
marketplace to attach an abstract
representative token to everything from
video games to labor unions now
proponents of web 3 will disagree with
this assessment particularly the claim
that cryptocurrency is endemic to web 3
and the 2 are intractable but that's the
practical reality of the situation every
substantial project branding itself
under the banner of web 3 is strapped to
the side of a blockchain be it issuing
governance tokens or relying on the
chain smart contract layer or requiring
possession of a cryptocurrency in order
to pay the processing fees that are
mandatory in order to participate they
are at this point philosophically and
technologically entwined less accessible
less free less interesting and
substantially more expensive web 3 is
the vanguard of a million paywalls and
oppressive code enforced drm schemes
sold to idealist as a decentralized
system where they and not wealthy
stakeholders have the power i see
tremendous blind spots in a community
that has spent so long focusing on the
hype of an untenable fantasy metaverse
where they're the ones cowing
corporations with immutable ownership
guaranteeing their ability to resell
video game horse armor that they failed
to consider that the enforcement of
ownership can and will be used against
them if and when corporations decide to
leverage their power in the space the
fantasy amongst evangelists is that a
tokenized economy where digital goods
are mediated by nfts would give them
more power goods like digital games
would have true ownership encapsulated
in the ability to be resold but there is
no reason to believe that this is how
things would shake out the far far more
probable result is that the tokens are
used to lock products down even tighter
the squid game token scam is
illustrative here in early november 2021
a new meme token popped up styled after
the hit netflix show squid game over the
course of about a week the price of the
token was pumped from a few cents to
just under 3 000 u.s estimates are that
the squid developers took in about 3.38
million dollars before cashing out their
holdings deleting their socials and
vanishing into thin air a classic rug
pull but the truly
transcendental detail is that it left
buyers with not merely a useless token
but a token that couldn't be sold at all
built into squid was a requirement that
in order to transfer or sell the tokens
a corresponding number of marbles tokens
needed to be spent at the same time the
hitch was that marbles were never
available no rules were broken in this
scam and indeed the squid tokens do
exactly what they say they do if you
have the appropriate amount of marbles
tokens you can absolutely transfer or
sell your squid
just good luck getting any a game
developer can in any of myriad ways
deliver on a truly owned digital token
that is rendered untradeable in practice
and all by playing by the rules
rules must always be evaluated for their
power to oppress this is a blind spot to
crypto enthusiasts because they just
assume that they're the early adopters
they're the ones who will have power
they're the ones who will get to set the
rules and they're the ones who will do
the oppressing consider that any token
that can be used to grant access can
also be used to revoke it like let's say
that i create a hangout spot in one of
the metaverse contender platforms
decentraland and we call it the ahigao
alpaca oasis the oasis has a backroom
that only allows registered players to
enter meaning you need to have your meta
mask linked to decentraland in order to
get in this type of gate is typically
used to create vip areas places where
only people who hold a specific token or
class of token can enter only people
with official ahigao alpacas can enter
but
as is well known within the lore of the
metaverse the ahigao alpacas have long
been at war with the board ape yacht
club so rather than checking for an
alpaca token i check for ape tokens and
then forbid entrance or maybe i just
make my game artificially more difficult
for them or inflate my prices now
imagine that instead of running a
hangout spot in a video game that i'm a
decentralized finance organization
giving out mortgages in cryptocurrency
and i scour your transaction history for
donations to the naacp as part of my
risk assessment protocol imagine that
nestle is able to track unionization
efforts in real time because the union
is issuing governance tokens on a
publicly auditable blockchain the belief
that the world will be fairer if the
rules are enshrined in code enforced by
computers and made extremely difficult
to change or circumvent is laughable
it's not merely naive but categorically
ahistoric this is where a lot of my
resistance comes from you can create
specialized cryptochains that have a
negligible environmental impact but the
force of that model is culturally
destructive the current system sucks but
this is just a worse version of the
current system it doesn't even stop
there it's tokens all the way down this
game has a a good high barrier of entry
so most people can't do it unless they
have what's called a scholarship where
someone essentially pays for their
barrier of entry to allow them to play
the game and then they can split the
profits afterwards like okay axe
infinity is a so-called play-to-earn
video game based on ethereum but because
ethereum is too slow and expensive to
interact with directly the developers
sky mavis created a side chain called
ronin which consists of a governance
currency called axs the game character
tokens called axes and the in-game
currency called smooth love potions or
slp all of these components are built to
function as money because that's what
the machine is built to do the so-called
play to earn model is a great case study
in what the end result of the crypto
econ system actually looks like axi
infinity gets a lot of credulous
coverage from the press because a
handful of people in the philippines are
able to make a marginal living by
playing the game and flipping their slp
which lets skye maven turn around and
pretend that they're a humanitarian
organization and not a for-profit
business who makes money off all the
people rushing to buy a team of axes
believing that they can get paid just
for playing now real quick axey infiniti
is a lightweight card based pvp game
where players fight with a team of three
critters called axes it's a bit pokemon
and a bit slay the spire axes have
randomized attributes and are all
tokenized so if you sell an axi you're
selling that specific axi smooth love
potions are used to breed axes and thus
form the basis of the economy as they
are fungible relative to the axes
themselves matches are either ranked or
unranked but only ranked matches entered
using energy which recharges every day
can earn slp the amount of energy you
have to work with depends on the number
of axes in your wallet and ranges from
20 to 60. additionally higher ranked
matches are worth more slp more slp
means a bigger stable of axes which
means more energy to play matches more
flexibility within the metagame better
team compositions and baseline better
stats enabling easier wins so the
difference in earning potential between
higher and lower ranked accounts is
pretty substantial
what coverage tends to note and then
quickly move on from is the fact that
the game is extremely expensive to
onboard costing hundreds of dollars to
assemble a basic team which has led to
the rise of what are euphemistically
called scholarship programs businesses
like wales scholars that set up a large
number of accounts give players access
to the game account but not the
underlying wallet and then pay players a
split of the slp the account generates
whale scholars and other mentorship
businesses retain full control of the
wallet and thus the axes the slp and any
axs it's capitalism in its rawest form
players invest their time into grinding
slp and then the owners take half the
returns players get to barely make
minimum wage while the owners who are
taking 50 from dozens if not hundreds of
players get to speculate on digital land
look what the whale scholars just got
we have land in the arctic baby
we have arctic land
axis energy system is fundamentally
broken in how it promotes this exact
middleman arrangement if you have 21
axes in your wallet you can create one
account that has 60 energy at its
disposal or you can create seven bare
minimum accounts with 20 energy each a
high ranked account with 60 energy will
dramatically outperform a single low
ranked account with 20 energy but seven
accounts that are played daily by other
people is far and away the best roi
because it involves doing basically
nothing except collecting your cut even
more illustrative between august and
october 2021 the internal economy of axi
infinity crashed not absolute rock
bottom but bad enough that all but the
highest ranking players fell below the
average daily wage in the philippines
with low ranked players falling below
minimum wage navic a think tank and
consulting firm that does deep research
on game economies has done a pretty deep
and thorough analysis of the axi economy
and in their write-up they identify the
core sources psychological players
aren't playing to play the game they're
playing to make money they treat the
game as a job and thus have little
interest in the game items for their own
sake once they have enough stuff to
cover their job they stop reinvesting
and start cashing out the price of low
quality axes the ones that new players
are likely to buy in order to onboard
for the lowest cost possible is propped
up entirely by players buying them
roughly at the same rate they're
generated this requires either mentors
to be scaling up their teams by buying
axes instead of generating them or new
players injecting new money into the
ecosystem by onboarding but the more
players that are playing the more slp
and axes that will be generated thus the
fundamentally unsustainable economic
model where an infinite supply of new
players must enter the ecosystem forever
purely to keep the price stable if it
tips one way or the other you either get
runaway inflation or runaway deflation
this happens all the time in games games
bork their internal economy constantly
it just doesn't normally matter because
you're talking about completely
fictional gold or gems or dragon bones a
truly stable economy isn't even
desirable from a gameplay standpoint
anyway
gentle inflation ends up helping newer
and more casual players by driving down
the cost of things in the in-game
economy which lets those players
participate and have fun of course if
your pitch is play to earn and not play
to have fun where the optics of buoying
up the fictitive valuation of your
company rests entirely on the assumption
that players can earn then that's of a
bit of a different incentive set isn't
it more people play axey infinity to try
and make money than play it because it's
a game they enjoy this is a fundamental
flaw in the model if you pitch your game
based on earning potential you are going
to attract people seeking to
industrialize your platform faster and
in greater numbers than would otherwise
play this is exactly the parasitic
situation that games for decades now
have been actively minimizing because it
creates vicious negative externalities
if players can sell their in-game stuff
then it changes the way that they play
the game it changes the way that they
optimize their play time since the vast
majority of games are openly a
non-investment a straight exchange of
money for entertainment also known as a
purchase players tend to optimize their
play time for intangible returns like
fun distraction socialization relaxation
challenge achievement and narrative
fulfillment with absolutely no
expectation that the money and time they
put in should return anything other than
those things
the key shift here and the meaningless
buzz phrase that you'll encounter online
is the proposition that the results of
playing a game should retain value which
is code for having a potentially
speculative price
in order to try and keep the grift mill
running for another few months sky maven
have tweaked the economy to reduce the
amount of slp players can earn per hour
it's a nightmarishly thin edge to be
walking on and the main thing hit has
managed to accomplish is enabling an
entire strata of pit bosses running
teams of players grinding out smooth
love potions and like all bosses they
have not taken the downturn in stride
and have instead started cracking the
whip we do not accept mediocre gaming
anymore need at least 120 to 150 slp a
day and those who yield more will be
rewarded with additional percentage
i prioritize those who have gaming
experience we have a separate program
for charity evangelists like to point to
this as though it's inspiring people in
economically disempowered countries able
to make a meager living by simply
playing a video game i reject that
framing it's horrifying our global
system is so fundamentally unjust that
people are patting themselves on the
back for generating a whole new kind of
online uw pit boss who tells you to
grind harder or you're fired but caps it
off with a blushy emoji oopsie looks
like someone didn't meet their quota
this sucks
i think the thing that normies don't get
about nft bros is their dedication the
staggering volume of capital they
already control and how deeply rooted
they are in the culture of the people
who operate the platforms we all use
every day and that alone is a good
reason for people to pay attention they
have a lot of money and a lot of clout
that they can use to try and make fetch
happen this is something of a splitting
point basically the future shakes out in
one of two broad ways one is that some
new technological buzzword comes along
and blockchain and web3 lose their sway
over investors the stream of new buyers
dries up and the early investors cash
out as best they can popping the whole
bubble the other is that they're
successful and cryptocurrency is able to
crowbar its way into enough corners of
our lives that it becomes unavoidable
we're all forced in some way to maintain
a crypto wallet to manage whatever coins
and tokens become necessary for
participation in society providing early
investors with a captive audience and
steady flow of capital to quote german
socio-technologist jurgen gouder better
known by his online alias tantei there
are parts of your digital life that
currently you can't really sell but
that's what they want to change
everything needs to be bought and sold
everything is just a vehicle for more
speculation the reason they want you to
be able to resell your access token to
some service instead of buying or
renting it like today is to create even
more markets for speculation and the
smart contracts can be set up in a way
that at every corner they profit the
claims that this technology facilitates
an immutable ledger of ownership is
itself largely hollow posturing even
from within the ecosystem remember that
most of the actual things being
referenced are not contained within the
chains themselves because the chains are
too slow restrictive and bad at their
job to actually store media and because
many of the things being sold are purely
ephemeral the ipfs address for any given
media token can be effortlessly minted
onto another competing chain or even the
same chain that's not even right click
saving that's referencing the exact same
media why is the token on ethereum more
authoritative than the token on tezos or
cardano or selena or ergo or celo or
binance or allegorant or polka dot or
eos or tron or v chain or ethereum
classic or phantom or stellar or stacks
or neo or waves or holo or link or radix
or harmony or oasis or icon or secret or
iota or crown or terror or omni or
enigma or elastos or edgeware bite them
or fuse or gather if a chain hard forks
which version of your stuff is the real
one bitcoin is itself mired in a turf
war between bitcoin bitcoin cash and
bitcoin sv the myth of immutable
ownership governed by these systems is
predicated on a monolithic victor in
reality your nfts within the ethereum
ecosystem are ultimately just as trapped
sandboxed and meaningless as your steam
trading cards you'll hear about
protocols like polygon that aim to let
you move stuff from chain to chain but
that's sleight of hand you can't remove
something from a chain so all they
really do is create a new token at the
destination and add a note to the bottom
of the original token that says i'm
currently somewhere else please don't
move or sell me it's an ask that's
governed by smart contracts so
vulnerable to bad coding in video game
terms they would be immediately hammered
looking for item duplication glitches a
vulnerability that's basically
inevitable in a mass adoption scenario
it's a system that is at once
impenetrable and brittle and that
arrangement disproportionately empowers
the dishonest one of the complications
is that it's basically impossible to
extricate the digital scarcity concepts
of nfts from cryptocurrency and the core
philosophies that cryptocurrency was
built from one rose out of the other and
they are basically forever entwined one
of the ironies of all this is that any
legitimate artistic or anti-capitalist
uses of the underlying technology are
contingent on the tech remaining niche
on a very basic level the systems just
suck being slow difficult to use and
generally oblique for the most part to
the degree that they're usable at all it
is largely at the mercy of only having a
few users there are blockchains that are
reasonably responsive and reasonably
cheap because they're not popular
hickednens is a well-regarded art market
on the tesla's blockchain transaction
fees and deflation are at the moment
relatively minimal and thus a lot of the
transactions are able to operate in the
range of 5 to 20 dollars but that state
exists by the grace of being 45th in
popularity just high enough to actually
have users but not high enough to have
attracted too many bots if tezos goes as
they say to the moon then that all
changes users adopt the platform
disproportionate to the scale of
validators the value of tez skyrockets
and the actual marketplace of people
using hickman's experience hyper
deflation where hoarders are rewarded
handsomely and buyers are punished okay
we need to pause here for a moment
because this is actually really
important but absurdly complex like
textbook length subject matter so here's
the short version deflation is
counterintuitive because the line is
going up which makes it look like a good
thing but it's only good if you already
have the currency in hand as the
purchasing power of a currency increases
typically because cash gets more scarce
the cost of goods and labor goes down a
deflationary economy punishes buying
things as anything that you buy today
will inevitably be cheaper to buy in the
future if you need to buy things that
aren't financial assets things that
don't appreciate in value like food
clothing rent vehicles transit fare you
screw yourself over this is hyper
deflation and it's not only designed
into cryptocurrencies with their hard
cap on total coin supply but considered
desirable by their creators and
evangelists this is what going to the
moon means
now let's talk about unions
using tokens to verify union membership
and participate in union activities
relies on the tech being oblique enough
that union busters and their clients
don't see it as a meaningful arena to
monitor also that ship has already
sailed union busters and gig economy
evangelists love crypto they love defy
and they love smart contracts and they
love nfts and why wouldn't they it's an
environment that demolishes consumer
protections and transfers tremendous
amounts of explicit power to the wealthy
in a lot of ways this is all just a
system for deferring trust onto machines
and pretending that there aren't humans
on the other end and if there's one
thing that union busters love it's the
prospect of an unbreakable individual
contract whose inequities can all be
blamed on a machine the current state of
the web concentrated in a few mega
platforms is the result of compounding
complexity we used to have a web where
anyone could learn to write a web page
in html in an afternoon it's just
writing text and then using tags to
format the text but over time people
understandably wanted the web to do more
to look better and so the things that
were possible expanded via scripting
languages that allowed for dynamic
interactive content soon the definition
of what a website was and looked like
sailed out of reach of casual users and
eventually even out of reach of all but
the most dedicated hobbyists it became
the domain of specialists so casual
users excluded by complexity moved to
templates services and platforms this
process gradually concentrated a
critical mass of users into a handful of
social media platforms already even
within the space new hegemons are
forming tremendous amounts of capital
and power are concentrating in
corporations like consensus who own
metamask and animoka brands who have
wide and deep investment in crypto
gaming openc the at present dominant
marketplace for tokens on a couple
different chains is filling the power
rules users need while the chain itself
is in theory the arbiter of truth
nothing prevents people from filling the
chain with lies and so arises a demand
for not merely a chain parser a service
that enables users to interact with the
chain but an interpreter of the chain
motivational speaker and dc mark calvin
bakara claimed to have lost three board
ape yacht club tokens to a social
engineering scam in reaction to this he
took to twitter to whip up a mob that
could pressure open c and two other
marketplaces into flagging the tokens as
stolen and blocking them from being sold
calvin was eventually able to re-secure
his tokens by paying a ransom because
that's really all you can do and he
doesn't seem to consider that from the
perspective of the thieves that's an
entirely desirable outcome they won
their plan worked this happens all the
time board apa members are particularly
susceptible targets of fraud owing to
their specific combination of greed and
low social literacy looking to avoid
paying platform fees and royalties many
of them moved off open c to doing
transactions on a shady little platform
called nft trader which allowed scammers
to run a very simple link swap scam and
steal at least a dozen different eight
tokens in the span of a couple days the
meat of calvin's incident is the way in
which the platforms that interact with
the chain are being deputized by users
to be the de facto authority not on what
the chain says but what the chain
means it is just a recreation of
existing power structures within the new
environment
now this is where evangelists insist
that the answer lies in daos
decentralized autonomous organizations a
revolutionary new way to organize people
that will allow for the decentralized
governance of these systems so that's
the claim but what is it exactly once
you strip off the paint a dao is an
organization whose membership roles and
privileges are governed by possession of
relevant tokens on a given blockchain
and it's also the underlying software
that executes relevant operations
that's kind of really about it so just
to be very clear here a conceptual dow
consists of three things
people
a digital machine built of smart
contracts and a token that allows the
people to interact with the machine
in practice
most things that call themselves dows
don't have the machine at all and a
substantial number either don't have the
token or
only have the token the upside of a dow
is that it makes it easy-ish to create a
formal organization at theoretically any
scale from only a couple people to a
massive pool of stakeholders and the
program layer makes it possible to
automate certain activities and the
results if the organization votes via
the dow interface the results of that
vote are automatically recorded and
potentially executed though that framing
is misleading as with tokens themselves
there's no inherent functionality in a
dao it's just a box that code goes into
i might as well be referring to all the
things you could do with a web page
as already mentioned many organizations
presenting themselves as a dow have no
machine functionality at all it's pretty
standard to find a dao that has issued a
governance token the script that's used
for voting with the systems to actually
use that token being placed somewhere in
the nebulous future of the road map that
open-endedness is actually important
because while the claim is that these
machines will further democratize the
internet the technical complexity that
they add the new specialized programming
expertise that they require concentrates
a lot of power in the hands of people
who can build the templates that in turn
enable non-programmers to actually use
it it's just laying the seeds for the
future recreation of the status quo the
facebook google amazon dominated
internet arose because the technical
cost of building a modern website rose
far beyond what the vast majority of
amateurs could manage so everyone moved
to templates and then to services and
finally to platforms this doesn't even
reset the clock on that the technical
cost of creating a dow is already far
beyond any casual amateur in part
because all of this is being built by
programmers and in part because of the
stakes the only thing this stuff is
truly good for is managing on-chain
assets a dao program can see the state
of the chain and interact with it so the
dao humans can vote on what should
happen to those assets and then the dao
program can automatically act on the
results but that raises the stakes
because a dao can see and interact
directly with on-chain assets there's
the risk that via bad programming or
unforeseen exploits a malicious actor
can use a dow to access all kinds of
stuff the risk is directly proportional
to the value of the assets kept on chain
and remember again that evangelists want
to put everything on chain the hilarious
thing is that this has already played
out once before in fact it played out
with the first dao ever built called the
dao
this whole story unfolds over the course
of three months in 2016 from april to
june the dow was an ethereum based
venture capital fund that aimed to use
code to create an investment firm
without a conventional management
structure or board of directors a scheme
that's positioned as lightweight and
reducing bureaucratic overhead but
really it just translated to an attempt
at minimizing human liability for the
actions and behaviors of the fund this
unparalleled expression of greed made
the major speculative players in
ethereum so horny that during the april
and may pre-sale they funneled 14 of the
entire volume of ether into the dao
central wallet now because the dao's
underlying code was open source experts
and malicious actors alike were able to
pour over it for vulnerabilities and
indeed vulnerabilities were found
however because at the end of the day
fleshy humans are the ones actually
pushing buttons and making decisions the
actual leadership of the nominally
leaderless dao horny for money and
prestige decided to launch in late may
anyway three weeks later the dao's
programming was exploited and the
attacker was able to transfer one-third
of the dao's funds into a holding wallet
about five percent of the entire
ethereum economy valued at the time
around 16 to 17 million dollars now
because this threatened the bottom line
of capital holders the ethereum project
as a whole the entire thing was almost
immediately forked in order to undo the
hack and protect the interests of the
wealthy ethereum classic the arm of the
fork that didn't undo the attack
persists to this day though it's notably
less popular despite being demonstrably
more principled because all the talk
about decentralization is a myth it's
just words at the end of the day the
guy's in charge the guys who built the
system to serve their interests are
still in charge and keep a kill switch
in their back pocket crypto is barely a
decade old and organizations deemed too
big to fail already exist the whole
fiasco laid out the truth from the word
go calling a dao a revolutionary
structure is smoke and mirrors it's just
voting shares you might as well call
apple a bold experiment in democracy
because a baker's judges and individuals
make the decisions instead of just one
regardless of the future pitfalls dows
are also extremely limited they are
again just code well evangelists promise
that they can reinvent the social
organization mentally consider all the
problems conflicts and decision making
that social organizations deal with and
ask how many of those even can be solved
by code some of them can easily be
turned into computer programs automated
bookkeeping payouts collections data
tracking sure that's all stuff
organizations conceptually can make use
of but how do you code for the fact that
red just really doesn't get along with
blue the pitch promises organizations
bound by unbreakable rules but how many
organizations actually benefit from that
level of rigidity in particular what
happens when the version of the rules
enforced by code run up against a
complication that the coders didn't
consider what happens if someone with
legitimate stake in the dow starts
spamming the organization's internal
systems with bad requests what if not
enough people participate in voting what
if the system locks itself up what if
the rules are rigged what if the system
commits a crime if this technology did
see mass adoption a future time bomb
already exists in the fact that very
very few of these systems have factored
mortality into the considerations of
their structure because what if someone
with an important token dies is a really
easy thing to overlook when you're kind
of insulated tech bro who reinvents
vending machines and calls them bodega
boxes now all of these hypotheticals are
technically addressable you can build
contingency systems that can account for
them but then you need to consider
contingencies for those contingencies
because what if someone uses systems
intended for dealing with deceased or
absentee members to expel people they
just don't like and again you can only
use code to enforce interactions that
the programmers make enforceable via the
code constitution dao a hastily set up
scheme to bid on one of the few
remaining original copies of the us
constitution already ran aground most of
these problems as the project failed to
win the auction and is now trying to
issue refunds a thing that the slap dash
machine was never intended to do the
reality is that most organizations with
any meaningful social complexity even
tiny organizations like video game
guilds are too complex to properly
express and code there's too many
contingencies and contingencies for
those contingencies and contingencies
for those contingencies to account for
so rather than trying to turn social
interactions into code the dow is
marginalized into only handling code
appropriate tasks like bookkeeping
digital signature verification and
on-chain asset management but that's not
a revolutionary new way to organize
people
that's just a productivity tool the dow
can have a process for voting on actions
but the moment the outcome of those
actions move off-chain i.e into the real
world the dao program is powerless the
program can't make humans execute the
decisions of the group that's still an
analog problem the whole thing very
quickly runs into an incentive wall
where it's just faster and easier to
solve problems verbally via abstract
trust relationships and promises to the
same end results this is why it's so
common for dows to not actually have any
of the inner machine that would actually
make them into what they claim to be
it's easier to just not taken as a whole
dows aren't some revolutionary new model
they're a tool built onto the side of
cryptocurrency that only has meaningful
advantages when interacting with
cryptocurrency as a tool for speculative
trading and managing financial
instruments the rest is just a gimmick a
slow inflexible tool for executing straw
polls again a lot of these boil down to
a scheme to minimize liability on the
part of the creators the creators of
inuyasha token a meme coin dao based on
nothing except the ephemeral concept of
the inuyasha anime demonstrated this
admirably when they were pressed on the
issue of copyright openly trading on a
known brand specifically for clout their
answer to the question boils down to one
a failure to understand copyright and
two an insistence that it doesn't matter
because no one's responsible the dow did
it no
humans are liable just this amorphous
sentient carbon cloud you have a really
good way you explain it about the um
about the copyright issue that
everyone's afraid of because they don't
want to invest in a token that's going
to be told to like cease and desist or
right yeah so i mean to clear that up i
think first you have to distinguish
between a mark
and copy
right um so right now on the website
there's
it's all custom art done by stephen
your friend stephen so there is no copy
i mean the only person that can really
copyright us right now is steven
uh you know
well what about logo likeness or
character likeness
yeah so trademarks um it's possible that
the inuyasha mark
it could could become scrutinized
however
we're a decentralized autonomous
organization officially and the token is
launched on the ethereum blockchain so
there's there's really no going back
i'm just a community member um i'm not
an owner like there's there's really no
single entity that has ownership over
this so i mean it it's on the blockchain
now
there's no going back and that bit also
just so brilliantly demonstrates the
underlying mentality of a lot of these
guys they wanted to use the inuyasha
brand for clout but they didn't want to
ask for permission because they would
probably get rejected so they did it
anyway so now that it's on chain it
can't be easily taken down so
i guess you just gotta let them do it
it's on the blockchain now
there's no going back things get funny
in that frustrating way when you do come
across a dow that's trying to be
legitimate and they tip their hand by
revealing that underneath they're
legally a co-op or an llc or some other
extant legal entity unless your goal is
a grift there's nothing truly
revolutionary about their structure or
functionality li jin the co-founder of a
bunch of predatory venture capital firms
that focus on polishing the image of the
gig economy to distract from the ways in
which it's eroding labor has an extended
twitter thread where she tries to pitch
daos as the future of unions though her
rationale is not only shaky relying
heavily on magical thinking it's also
peppered with inexplicable lies for
example she champions yield guild a dow
that she describes as a gaming guild
comprised of thousands of play to earn
gamers an on-ramp that brings more
players into play to earn gaming it can
represent gamers and lobby game devs for
better policies its scale also enables
the collective to offer benefits and
protections eg healthcare paid time off
that would be infeasible if gamers were
operating on their own
this is a tremendous overstatement of
what yield actually is it's not a union
nor does it function as a union nor does
it have aspirations of functioning as a
union it's not even a dow though it does
have aspirations of transitioning into
being one it's at best a mildly
decentralized cartel that's
experimenting with shaking down players
with the promise of helping them by
gamifying the process of participating
in the guild in practice it's a discord
server that helps play to earn players
find sponsorships pivot from one game to
another and generally [ __ ] about how
much their jobs suck in fact in response
to legion's tweets the server residents
had this to say
i've read that through the ygg dow
members are able to get access to
healthcare
is this true is there any more info on
this anywhere to learn more about what
is offered or is this still in the works
as a freelancer i'm always interested to
learn about more options
i actually don't know about that that
would be awesome to get partnered with
healthcare where did you get that info
though we haven't heard of any kind
about it hmm
yeah i think lee used it as an example
of potential benefits and didn't mean it
literally but nothing of that sort has
been discussed yet now on a functional
level most dows use an administrative
system based off the use and spending of
internal script the governance tokens
there's a decent amount of variability
in how they're used but basically they
function either as proportional voting
power exactly the same as voting shares
in a publicly traded company fiat voting
power where there's no point in
possessing more than one or direct
voting power where tokens are spent to
cast votes and more tokens can be spent
to cast more votes typically this script
can be bought and sold even on a
secondary market and indeed possession
of it is typically a definitional part
of membership rather than structuring
like a union yield's overt goal for
their dow is to function as a hedge fund
using the exchange value of their token
as a means to raise funds to invest into
play to earn games and allowing yield
members to spend their tokens to rent
these dow owned resources in fact yield
is so far removed from the purpose and
functionality of a union that the road
map includes potentially implementing
what's called holographic consensus
which is a futures market where
participants gamble on what proposals
will or won't be passed using their
governance tokens as the stakes it's
amazing if you wanted to build a machine
whose sole purpose is to concentrate
political power slowly over time
additionally many use a proof-of-stake
staking system to reward members with
additional tokens with no gate on how
many tokens any single member can hold
this whole arrangement creates a system
where participants with only a few
tokens are incentivized to not vote
against the interests of highly staked
members plus anything you spend limits
what you can stake and thus reduces all
future income of tokens which means even
less voting power in the future members
who possess a disproportionate share of
tokens can afford to outspend on the
outcome of any vote and still retain a
proportional future voting power at best
you end up with high powered voting
blocks and at worst a functional
monopoly the internal discourse of yield
is like all crypto focused on the price
of the dao script and not its actual
functionality within the organization
rather than creating a more equitable
democratic organization that looks out
for the needs of all its members yield
is a scheme that explicitly rewards its
highest stakeholders with more power and
access
now conceptually you could make a doubt
that behaves towards actually useful
worker-focused goals but you could also
do that without a doubt because it's
just an organization the dao itself is
just a mechanism of an organization and
more often than not its involvement is
little more than tech fetishism so most
actual dows don't resemble anything like
a flat hierarchy in fact the ability to
buy and sell voting power and the
hierarchy that results is seen as a
strict advantage in that it allows
emotionally uninvested members to make
money and gives them a thing that they
can reward people with that will align
incentives and despite the fact that lee
jin is directly involved with yield as
the philosopher in residence yield is
neither structured like a labor union
nor does it have ambitions to be one the
point is that thought leaders like lee
jin who get a lot of social traction by
promising that their techno-fetishistic
community are solving big societal
problems are liars they love the
pageantry of democracy because it allows
them to pretend to be democratic because
they can paint their detractors as being
undemocratic it's all hollow hand-waving
and techno-babble to distract from the
fact that it's just shareholding it's
the corporatization of everything the
conversion of the entire world into
claims governed by power granted via
token possession and enforced by
machines that allow humans to wash their
hands of the outcomes at the end of the
day every dow pretending to be useful is
still a forced entry point to some hype
driven meme coin whose existence only
benefits its creators and the exchange
that sells it
[Music]
in 2008 the economy functionally
collapsed the basic chain reaction was
this bankers took mortgages and turned
them into something they could gamble on
this created a bubble and then the
bubble popped when you drill down into
it you realize that the core of the
crypto ecosystem the core of web 3 the
core of the nft marketplace is a turf
war between the wealthy and ultra
wealthy techno fetishists who look at
people like bill gates and jeff bezos
billionaires minted via tech industry
doors that have now been shut by market
calcification and are looking for a
do-over looking to synthesize a new
market where they can be the one to
ascend from a merely wealthy programmer
to a hyper-wealthy industrialist it's a
cat fight between the five percent and
the one percent ultimately the driving
forces underlying this entire movement
are economic disparity the wealthy and
tenuously wealthy are looking for a
space that they can dominate where they
can be trendsetters and taste makers and
can seemingly invent value through sheer
force of will this is in my opinion the
blind spot of many casual critics the
fact that tokens representing ape pfps
are useless yet somehow still expensive
isn't an overlooked glitch in the system
it's half the point it's a digital
extension of inconvenient fashion it's a
flex and a form of myth-making and
that's how it draws in the bottom people
who feel their opportunities shrinking
who see the system closing around them
who have become isolated by social media
and a global pandemic who feel the
future getting smaller people pressured
by the casualization of work as jobs are
dissolved into the gig economy and want
to believe that escape is just that easy
all you gotta do is bet on the right
discord and you might be air dropped the
next new hotness it could be you plucked
out of the crowd on wearable and
bestowed a six-figure price by an
elusive emirati music producer get a
bake in your wallet hotel like a good
diamond hands and enjoy that yield all
you need is five thousand dollars in
seed money and you can buy a farmer's
world milk cow and if you milk that cow
every four hours day and night for two
weeks why there's all your money back
right there and now it's pure profit
minus naturally the overhead of all the
wax you needed to stake the barn you
needed to buy and build the barley you
needed to purchase and grow the food you
needed to buy to refill the energy you
needed to milk the cow build the barn
and grow the barley plus you actually
need to cash out which isn't getting
paid it's quitting this is your chance
to stick it to wall street and the
venture capitalist as long as you pay no
attention to the vcs behind the curtain
the line
can only go up it's a movement driven in
no small part by rage by people who
looked at 2008 who looked at the system
as it exists but concluded that the
problems with capitalism were that it
didn't provide enough opportunities to
be the boot and that's the pitch buy in
now buy in early and you could be the
high tech future boot our systems are
breaking or broken straining under
neglect and sabotage and our leaders
seem at best complacent willing to coast
out the collapse we need
something better but a system that turns
everyone into petty digital landlords
that distills all interaction into
transaction that determines the value of
something by how sellable it is and
whether or not it can be gambled on as a
fractional token sold via micro auction
that's not it a different system does
not inherently mean a better system we
replace bad systems with worse ones all
the time we replaced a bad system of
working bosses with a terrible system of
apps gigs and on-demand labor so it's
not just that i oppose nfts because the
foremost of them are aesthetically
vacuous representations of the dead
inner lives of the tech and finance bros
behind them it's that they represent the
vanguard of a worse system the whole
thing from open sea fantasies for
starving artists to the buy-in for
pay-to-earn games it's the same holo
exploitative pitch as mlms it's amway
but everywhere you look people are
wearing ugly ass ape cartoons
[Music]
you